[Applause]
[Music]
are we live am I watching the show and
and is that the problem we are oh my God
we live caught me watching my own show I
like the opening theme [__]
me f and [__] you for getting on my dick
for liking the opening theme man like
let a guy enjoy his opening theme but
that opening theme means only one thing
Mark [__] show began welcome to fat
man beyond man I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark
Bernard hey
h uh as you can see Mark is on the Death
Star and I am ready to load you on to
the Jungle Cruise ride at
Disneyland this show is brought to you
by Disney
pretty much cross the boards Disney we
own your childhood
[__] um I uh am still still moving
in um in Studio City oh thank you and um
I'm still trying to figure out sus out
where I will be oh you rock thank
you um where I will be setting up shop
in the uh hey yeah rock thank you um
where I'm going to be setting up
shop uh going forward I I assume it'll
be down in the garage where my office is
but the internet signal doesn't reach
down there yet I've been preoccupied for
the last month uh and change I've not
been home here in Los Angeles Mark I've
been back east in New
Jersey uh at SM castle and all around SM
Castle um working on a motion picture we
were lucky enough to get a waiver
uh the interterm
agreement and uh that we signed with the
um The Writers Guild folks no the SAG
folks rather and um we uh got to make a
movie which was uh really wonderful made
the the 430 movie It's called and you
know at one point in the midst of you
know the SAG strike which is not yet
over uh we had a day where we had a
hundred sag actors on the payroll they
were all happy to be working for the
moment and stuff it was very nice movie
turned out very incredibly sweet um I
look forward to sharing it with folks
I'm already done with the edit I I was
editing you know I like to cut W the
movies being made and stuff so um I was
cutting the whole time we were shooting
so you know you can watch The Flicks
probably my shortest flick uh I've ever
made like right now pre-credits it's
like 75 minutes oh wow it's tight it's
lean and it's uh you know the whole
movie I was like man these [__] kids
should curse more it's set in
1986 so having people curse more felt
didn't feel
authentic you know what I'm saying like
in 1986 we weren't all like you know
[__] [__] and [__] like that um
but yeah we we were we were Sailors in
New York oh were you oh yeah because
like that's when you first discover that
stuff and you it's it's like your first
[__] sip of alcohol like what this I
can sit these words have power and I'm
just gonna start like every time my
parents weren't around it was a [__]
Richard prior night at the OK
Corral um I mean that's just me because
again we were you know New York City
Hooligans um don't [__] belittle and
Sham me just because I didn't come from
New York godamn it spent 30 years of a
career care proving that Jersey rocks
just as hard God damn it all I'm saying
is you guys are you guys are from the
south like anytime I cross a bridge I'm
in the
South uh it's kind of true the
um yeah it was
uh I mean maybe it's just by virtue of
the fact that I was raised by
Grace like you couldn't curse there was
no cursing in my world not until not
until I met and started hanging out with
Jason Muse then the cursing started
seeping I mean honestly I was thinking
about it while I was making this movie
like cursing I didn't really curse
around in front of my mom until [__]
after clerks got picked up and I proved
that it was financially viable to curse
and then uh that's when I felt free I
was thinking about it a lot while I was
making the movie man while I
was making
clerks really like freed me up even
though I was like 23 I was still very
much like
under um my mom's thumb and not in a
horrible way she's not like a horrible
person but oh my God I was
so like the last child the baby I didn't
leave the nest and [__] like that so you
know
life proceeded even though I graduated
from high school like life had proceeded
while I was in high school so you know
my adolescence got extended in that in
that scenario long before like Clerk
afforded me the ability to artificially
extend my adolescence by just never
growing up and making pretend for a
living you know staying [__] home
until I was
202 you know extended my adolescence to
a large degree there but but making
clerks and clerks getting picked up and
[__] like that that recreated my
relationship um with my mom I thought
about it a lot while I was making this
movie maybe it because we shot [__] the
430 movie literally one mile from
[__] where we shot clerks our opening
day of the of the shoot we were two
blocks from quickstop we started
shooting in Leonardo we shot in Leonardo
Highlands Atlantic Islands mostly we
shot at my movie theater when when I
bought the movie theater Last year me
and my friends one of the first things I
said was like I'm gonna [__] write a
script for movie theater man like how
could I not so there was uh
no doubt whatsoever that I was GNA set a
flick there and uh I wrote this little
payon to my youth and and uh first date
with my high school girlfriend Kim
lockran um and it's about me and my
friend Ernie odonnell the guy who's SM
Castle keeper Ernie odonnell and our
friend Bellos Michael Bellos so it's you
know one day in 1986 where the kids like
go theater hopping at the local multi
multilex pay for one movie theater you
sneak into the rest something you you
know you wouldn't even I don't know if
you would even bother doing
nowadays um or I guess it's easier to
get away with [__] they they want
anybody in a movie theater if you pay
for one movie as long as you're buying
popcorn they probably don't give a [__]
uh but now seats are like pre-assigned
and whatnot so maybe it's maybe it's
different but I was a kid man you could
pay for like one movie go to
Multiplex and that was the dawn of the
multiplex and you can hop from movie to
movie you spend all day your parents
drop you off in the morning for the
first matina and then they pick you up
at like 10 o'clock 11 o'clock at night
so it's a real snapshot of that time and
so because of that there's not a lot of
cursing and the whole time I was making
the movie Mark all I could like my big
fear was like maybe I should be letting
people curse like maybe I should be why
am I stopping them from cursing like
ratings don't matter anymore right now
as it stands [__] movie is
probably a
PG-13 it's pretty innocent um but you
know I was like why do you even care
about ratings anymore do ratings even
matter like in a world where you can
watch PornHub on your phone like what is
a ratings what's the ratings board doing
anymore like does that stop anybody from
watching a movie you can access a movie
digitally within a month of its
theatrical life if it's lucky enough to
have one so well I tell you um a friend
of mine who's been on the podcast before
my friend AAA Cooper she wrote Megan
and I remember she I watched within the
last month yeah yeah yeah you know what
it reminded me of remember when we were
kids that Wes Craven movie Deadly friend
uhhuh it's deadly friend it's a little
bit Chucky like it's kind of all of that
stuff yeah yeah but it was watch oh she
was telling me about some of the
conversations about like she wrote a
horror movie She Wrote a straight up
[__] hormon and the conversations
with blumhouse about like you know I
hope I'm not speaking out of turn but
the the possibilities that open up if a
movie's PG-13 versus R and I think what
ended up working out in their favor it
was PG-13 and then it become a it became
a movie that like teenage girls could
have Movie parties for like it became
like if you're 14 years old we're having
a birthday party at the movie theater
I'm inviting all my friends we're all
going out if it's R you can't do that
you know and that movie crost $100
million and I I think in good part
because it opened up that chunk of
demographic once it became Megan once it
became something of a phenomenon um I
think it was a smart decision um it
doesn't happen all the time most movies
it probably doesn't matter but like
there is that sweet spot that if you're
willing to sacrifice a little bit of
blood and gore that you can maybe get a
high school audience that you might not
have been able to get before if
theatrical it's your play Megan was
PG-13 right it was yeah yeah yeah I
remember watching it being
like
[__] I remember thinking so smart not
to be
gory you you could play to like a
pre-teen audience you know because it's
like it was a horror it was a it was
blumhouse joint right presumably horror
but like you know when you get into the
realm of
like [__] high-tech doll and [__] you
know there's also a degree of of wink
wink nudge nudge kind to the whole
Affair like I don't I didn't get the
impression they were putting out there
going like no seriously
Megan you know it's like they were like
yeah we're here we're at the killer doll
place in our [__] the life of our
company and we're happy with that we're
they were're very happy with it and they
put out the unrated cut on streaming and
on video which then gooses that whole
Market because like if you saw in the
theater you're like oh this could be
bloodier like welcome aboard everybody
right here's the bloodier version
and anybody saw Megan in theaters was
like this could be
blooder oh
yeah I think there's always an audience
is like this needs more blood you know
what father the bride needs more
blood excuse me
um what have I what have I
watched
recently
um oh [__] man I watched this
documentary
yesterday um
about Bild
thebear he on iTunes Bild thebear is
like over 25 years old now the bilder
bear
workshop and speaking of killer dolls
yes they made the docu this documentary
about the history of the company and I
would say it was about like 45 to
50 minutes of a straightup documentary
and then they paded it with a lot of
Comedy like Pete Holmes was going to see
the movie at a movie theater and he ran
into Jerry Mathers was the
Usher um John Lovitz was the voice of
the bilda bear who was hosting the show
and moving without moving his mouth um
and some of that stuff seemed kind of
extraneous but the story itself was
compelling because I I like I don't know
if you and your kids were if your kids
were in the
Build-A-Bear spot sweet spot my kid was
like just when that [__] that [__]
launched I want to say in 97 so my kid
was born in
99 bear was like always a big part of
our Lives um so the documentary when I
saw it I was like you know I'll take a
trip and it was it it was worth the trip
if if you've ever [__] with a build-a
bearer it meant anything to you across
the
Spectrum um I watched that and I watched
this documentary on HP well on max
called BS High you see that I saw that
yeah I you know honestly turning it on I
was like I a gonna get through 10
minutes of this because I don't give a
[__] about sports but that was not a
sports documentary as much as it was a
sports documentary it was [__] nuts
man like like look at this
sociopath but the whole time I'm
watching him be interviewed for this
movie like finally he arrives at the
same conclusion I arrived at 10 minutes
in which is like why would you sit for
this why would you do this interview and
he actually gets to that point in the
interview where he's like I don't know
why I did this it's like yeah you did
not help your case one
iota a fascinating documentary if you've
not heard about the which I didn't the
bishop Sycamore Scandal yeah which I I
remember when it was playing out in real
time when people were like is this
school real like I remember even seeing
the clips on Twitter where they would
have this the comment commentators for
the game that they played and they got
destroyed they're like this isn't even a
school like they don't have a home fi
like who are these kids where what's
happening here that was and that they
did an excellent job of compelling of
conveying that in the documentary
apparently these kids this High School
didn't really exist um this con artist
admittedly calls himself con artist in
the document um kind of puts together
this team which if they win or even
place you know or you know just or are
competitive in the
least this is the Bad News Bears yeah
like that's what blew my mind the whole
time I'm watching this I'm going like
if if things went
just 50% better on the
FEI it's a Disney movie it's [__]
it's the Mighty Ducks it's [__] every
sports movie you've ever seen where you
know the [__] The Underdogs the
downtrodden they shouldn't happen but it
happens and [__] and so the whole
time like I'm not saying like I agreed
with the main character or you know the
the guy but I could
see like whenever he was
talking his his life was
like and and his thoughts were
punctuated by pop culture
moments a lot of Pop Culture references
and yeah lot of Remember the
Titans and even Thanos and Marvel movies
and like but just seeing life through
the prism of a threea structure which is
like maybe again I'm not like uh I
sympathize for the guy or something like
that but like like I was not so hardcore
shitty judgy because like I
recognize a dreamer like I know he's a
con artist and the whole thing was a
scam but on some level that dude was
also like yeah but like if it
works like everyone lives happily ever
after he referred to himself as like
Hannibal Smith he loved the a team and
he loved Hannibal Smith because like
Hannibal Smith would always come up with
a plan
plan wouldn't go according to plan but
it would always work and like at one
point in the documentary cackles like I
love it when a plan comes together as if
all of this was his design to get to
this point like it was it's a
fascinating watch yeah like every like
every sports movie the engine is hope
but the thing of it is is that he's all
about the exploitation of Hope be like I
found a bunch of kids who have this
dream of being able to play at the
Collegiate level of getting into the
pros of using this as a stepping stone
and like so do I like I've got ideas
about how to run a team I've got ideas
about how to take us to the next level
but the thing that he never does is take
responsibility for that exploitation
like he 100% believes that everything he
did was above board um and he treated
those kids with as much respect and care
as anybody should where all of those
children I mean not to give away the
ending but they're all broken because of
the experience they had with him he by
the way
and by the way not even children like 22
23 he was [__] with the with the
dreams and hopes of like not even kids
but like 20 year olds 22 year olds like
but that's what was particularly heinous
about this is like you know think of
your dream whatever your dream is that
thing where you're like oh my God
[__] like that would make my life
that's what these kids feel about
football and somebody comes along and is
like
I can make your dreams come true I could
still take you division one even though
you don't have the grades and you
haven't been in the schools that LE lead
in that direction so it really was
praying
upon their their dreams which is what
every con artist or scam artist does
they find that thing that means
something to you and [__] work it and
stuff but no different than if somebody
were to like come to me pre [__]
clerks and be like you know I hear you
want to make movies I can make a movie
for you you just need to put together
all this money and [__] like yeah it's
it's every person who got off a bus in
Union Station in Hollywood and there's
some dude waiting there for you who's
like hey you want to be in movies I know
how to make you in movies and then [__]
goes wrong it is [__] fascinating and
also like a primer on how you can really
work the
system you know if you're willing to
live with a bunch of judgments against
you like they these they would put these
kids up in hotels
motels and basically they figured out if
you check into a motel say you know 50
rooms or some such
[__] and you're like we're going to be
here for like you know x amount of time
a month two
months um and you put no money down
except maybe like the opening deposit or
some s [__] you can get away of staying
at a place for like three months
three months that's when they'll they
boot you out so three months apparently
is a football
season so that's what he would do with
the school is like move kids into these
motels for like until they got evicted
and these evictions were under the kids'
names so it's something that will follow
them for the rest of their lives and
they had no
clue he was taking out credit cards in
their names yes and loans he took out
loans in their names
$20,000 [__] loans in the names of
the PPP
loans it
is you know again I ain't saying like
this this poor dude got railroaded he's
a he's a con artist but if things just
go in the D this direction this much
better he's [__] they're writing
books about him and they're Disney's
making movie about this unlikely
scenario of Outsiders who pushed against
the rules and redefined the game the
other thing I walked away just learning
which I had no idea about because again
I don't follow Sports at
all is there's a school called IMG which
is like the best athletic school high
school in the country and their program
because they did footage of their school
looks like a [__] College like yeah
this crazy money going on and I think
back in back in like the the 80s and 90s
IMG was also big in training tennis
players and I think like Andre aasy came
out of there I think Williams sisters
spent some time in there like that's
just what they would do is they would
Scout like the best players in the world
get them in the in this in the school
train them the [__] up and not even like
we're doing classes just we're teaching
tennis or we're teaching whatever the
[__] it is and then become their
managers as they went on into the pros
and got a piece of that money that they
that they invested in in their time and
training and then eventually began to
absorb other sports including football
and like if you do that if you get
enough kids coming out of there go to
the pros and you get 10% of their like
lifelong salary then yeah you can build
the Epcot Center of trading
facilities it's worth a watch kids if
even if you're not like I don't like
sports and [__] I'm not a sports person
but BS High I believe is called um for
Bishop Sycamore hi a BSI really
compelling
watch and uh you know not really
about the stuff we generally talk about
on this show but uh not outside the
parameters no there's definitely a
villain well yeah there's a bad guy
that's true he though uh welcome back
kids so it's been last time we did this
I guess was when we did a live from New
Jersey indeed yeah and in in August for
the the uh the uh keep Comm and Curry
on um can I show you two cool things
before we get going look at this screen
play
Oh thick as a dick thick as a dick is
right you dropped this from the house
you'll kill somebody uh this is the one
of the premiums this this year on uh
that Kevin Smith Club as we're doing
published versions of the screenplay you
join thatkevinsmith club.com also
doing challenge coins
son look at this look at that young
whipper snapper I know so it's
kevolution it's Kev Through the Ages so
it's a bunch of different looks this one
is uh Kev from 1999 to
2005 uh the next one is 20 5 to 2010 so
forth and so on apparently I changed my
looks like [__] Madonna so uh we
decided that's what we would make our
premiums at that Kevin Smith Club about
uh this this year
kids what are you waiting for don't
sleep on that Kevin Smith Club come join
us that Kevin Smith
club.com what else can I sell these kids
while I'm at it
oh I'm going to spala in Tampa this
weekend Florida I'm coming hard all over
your face neck and chest then I'm gonna
go see my mother afterwards how filthy
is that um so yeah in Tampa they used to
do a thing in Okala called spala and now
they're doing it in Tampa so you come
out and see me and Jay on Saturday I
think Jay is there Friday Saturday and
Sunday um and then in New
Jersey October 12th next week through
the 15th the SM Castle Film Festival the
second annual smog Castle Film Festival
uh launches uh the opening night
screening is chasing Chasing Amy with
filmmaker Sav Rogers so uh there's some
stuff I got to sell you tickets for that
it's my castle
cinemas.com
anyway uh we probably have bills to pay
as long as we're doing we do indeed we
have a new
sponsor
new
sponsor I was just going to hold it so
everyone thought that my [__] screen
glitched um who's the sponsor Mark tell
them the the sponsor is
fume be smart don't start kick the habit
and put it out before it puts you out
all phrases we've heard a hundred times
yet we still continue to do bad habits
like insert your own bad habit here
whatever you like but our sponsor fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that
consumed far too many of us fume is a
natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to help
you trade out your negative habit for a
positive
one stuff like Maple pepper what are the
other
flavors uh let's see Maple pepper I got
raspberry
lemon I got white cranberry orange
vanilla um sparkling grape
fruit what is this one more orange V
crisp
mint that's all I got those packets look
like condoms kids but they're flavors
for your fume man so if you're somebody
with an oral fixation if you just got to
have something in your mouth you got to
be sucking on it you gotta be blowing on
it and [__] like that you're one of
those cats man likes to pass the time
when you drive a car or whatnot fume
is absolutely lovely I don't know why
nobody thought of this [__] earlier
natural flavors it's all natural isn't
it Mark it is and fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural
flavors uh and with it with a new
adjustable airflow dial hear that on a
magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to
do so the easiest way to drop stop a bad
habit is to switch to a positive one and
fume is designed perfectly to do just
that it fumees gold to take to make
switching easy and even enjoyable there
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who successfully
switched when other Solutions didn't
work so head to tryf nume.com that's TR
fm.com and use the code Fatman to save
10% off when you get the journey pack
today the journey pack comes with three
unique flavors and the new version two
fume to help Kickstart your positive
habits that's TR
f.com and use the code Fatman to save an
additional 10% off your order
today and thank you to the good Folks at
fume for sponsoring this podcast we do
man we thank the good Folks at fume for
jumping on board with us try out fume
folks somebody in chat also said I don't
look like myself I don't know what that
means they were like who where is Kevin
Smith and what have you done with him
well because you're a tribal council and
so that's a it's a slightly weird look
for you that it's true the environment
is off he was wondering why oh look
who's here who's joined us kids it's B
man listening to you guys talk about
fume I can't help but remember several
months ago Kevin hitting the uh lavender
scent con
so somebody must have been watching the
show and said hey we have this product
that people can do just like Kevin Smith
hits the
lavender so
smart that's why that's why they're like
that guy the guy who was hitting the
lavender all hard man he'll know what to
do here we are thanks to fume for
jumping on board indeed or Le indeed
indeed um all right man let's uh let's
talk about some
[__] let's talk about some [__] we can
talk about uh I mean the the big news we
can talk about that which is you know if
you guys have been under a rock for the
last week or so um The Writers Guild of
America both East and West has uh has
reached a tentative deal with the
studios it has been approved by both the
board of the West and the Council of in
the East and now that deal is out for
ratification by the members um I voted
to ratify it um I I believe in this deal
I understand what it gets us I think
it's a good deal for us to get um I
think the ratification period ends like
next Monday or so and at which time if
the membership votes for it to pass it
goes there a bill how bill becomes a law
kids um now this is something if you've
been following this show
um you know we were deeply invested in
the strikes Mark's even far more
so uh than me Mark was on the line you I
was on the line twice three times twice
three times I think how many times you
were you on the lines
um over the course of the 148 days that
the writers were out there um probably
about 50 maybe 60 times um usually two
or three times s a week um for the
entirety of the Run
um and uh and you know it it ebed and
flowed you know like it started strong
the spirits were high by day like by
month two when it's like middle of July
and it's 100 degrees in the valley and
walking that picket line can be a little
bit hard but then the actors went on
strike on day 78 of the writer strength
the actors went out and much like uh
like any like any movie where the
Cavalry shows up to to save your Heroes
um the actor showed up to breathe some
fresh air and add a an inning of of good
relief pitching um to to the to the
picket lines and then for another 70
some odd days um both unions were out
there together and it was you know to
say it was hard is a bit of an
understatement because it's physically
exhausting physically taxing the the the
UN certainty of it because nobody knew
when it would end
um took a toll on everyone but when
adults finally sat down and had
conversations for Real about putting
this to bed it took three days three
days of negotiations of conversations
with with good faith towards bringing
this thing to a close and conversations
started on like a Friday and or Thursday
I think it was and uh and we had a deal
by Sunday night and
it's a good deal I saw Seth Meyers was
it Seth me no John Oliver I think um on
his show was talking about I'm glad they
made a deal but this is a deal they
could have made on day one absolutely
like there's there's there's a little
bit of resentment I mean listen there
was there was I'm not going to say it
was bad blood it was just boneheaded
gamesmanship on the part of the studios
to make it personal when it never had to
be to talk about things like we want
them to lose their houses in their
Apartments were in it until you know
people start to really really hurt um
that we were the ones being unreasonable
that you know ABC d& the the let's smear
the opposition Playbook what seemed to
have been their playbook but yeah like
we made a an offer they refused to
engage with it and didn't engage for 120
days and they could have done this it
took three it did need to take 148 and
that is that is entirely on the part of
the studios
who thought that resolve was a breakable
thing um and that's that's the biggest
frustration is that God we could have
been done with this in a month three
weeks two weeks a week you knew you were
going to make a deal because you had
to why did it have to take so long you
know and the actors now it doesn't seem
like it's going to take that long
because sag is currently meeting with
the the the studios and I hope that it
doesn't take that long I hope that it's
not another months before they get their
deal I hope that at this point everybody
realizes we just have to get back to
work we got the writers writing we got
to get the actors acting the directors
have been waiting like good boys for uh
the actors and the writers to get their
[__] together and it's together so and
girls um girls the uh yeah well some of
them have been sit
waiting some of us got fortunate and got
a waiver and got back to work and stuff
um but nice to see that everyone is now
heading back
as did the writers get everything they
wanted um no um but that is the that is
the reality of a negotiation like nobody
gets everything that they want
everybody's got to give um but the the
wga's position and I agree with it is a
we got we got something for everybody um
every every category of writer uh
received some kind of boost um
screenwriters got minimum increases they
got uh two-step deals which means that
if you're a screenwriter and you sell a
movie historically you got to deliver
one draft like I here's my first draft I
hope you like it and then they had to
decide whether or not to bring you back
and do a rewrite on that draft um lots
of times it would take the first draft
and say thanks very much we're going to
have another writer rewrite it and down
the line now we're guaranteeing a
two-step dealer which means that you
have to pay for at least one rewrite um
which is huge I mean that's real money
that's how that's how feature
screenwriters make their their living is
by doing drafts of scripts um comedyan
variet variety writers got minimums and
and and guaranteed numbers and weeks in
the room which they've never had before
um and TV writers which make up the bulk
of the of the wga membership um probably
got the most um they got minimums
increases which is great they got Health
imp penti health and pension increases
which is great um writing teams now can
be counted separately in terms of
meeting your minimums for health used to
be if you were in a because it's a
monetary thing like you've got to make
$42,000 a year to qualify for help if
you're in a writing team you're
splitting that
$42,000 which means that suddenly you
had to do twice as much work to qualify
for your your benefits now they've
erased that particular stipulation AI
protections are in place meaning that
you have to disclose if an AI If you're
receiving AI material to rewrite AI
cannot be the first writer on board so
even if you give somebody you know
here's a wonderful feature script about
a duck who learns how to tap dance then
whatever human you give it to becomes
their original idea stop giving out good
ideas that duck that tab his picture is
a winner that's Barbie big son
Barbie um get git on that danc and Duck
picture it's all about the exploitation
of miners we'll have a billion dollars
for heav S um you know we finally got
some transparency on the viewership for
streaming um things and there's actually
um incentives and performance-based
bonuses for streamers it's not as robust
as I think that they would have wanted
but it's still what never existed before
um there's uh Staffing requirements you
have to have a certain number of writers
on a TV show and that scales depending
on how many episodes that you're doing
um there's now a requirement to pay
certain writers on that staff to be
there for production which never used to
be there before um staff writers on TV
shows um didn't used to get paid to
write their scripts um now they do
um which writing is writing and they
always should have been but that had
never been the deal you know they
they've had they put um penalties I
suppose is the is not the quite quite
the right word but the mini room problem
where you would convene a writer's room
before a show got a green light and pay
those writers sort of scale as opposed
to whatever they negotiated for um it's
getting writers room work for a bargain
as opposed to paying people what they
should be getting paid it's become more
expensive to do mini rooms which will
incentivize them to just do a regular
room like it's a lot of stuff it's a lot
of stuff um they didn't get everything
they wanted I think they wanted stiffer
um AI protections they wanted weekly
payments for screenwriters they wanted
to uh have writers being paid especially
on a TV show to be in post-production to
be in the editing Bay because that is
also still writing um but that stuff
they're like Hey listen we couldn't get
everything we're going to try in the
next one every negotiation every three
years we go back to the table and try to
get better and better and better deals
for everybody but it's a pretty good
[__] deal it's a pretty good [__]
deal and and I was thrilled to to be in
the Palladium when the the wga sort of
announced Victory and they went over all
the terms of the deal and it was it was
this wonderful kind of rally was it was
it was a political rally for for a party
you can 100% agree
with
um and and it was it was a great way to
sort of thank the leadership and thank
the negotiating committee and thank Drew
[__]
carry for spending what had to have
been millions of dollars over the course
of the strike because I'm not sure if
you remember this Kev but if you were in
The Writers Guild of America and if you
went to Bob's Big Boy in Burbank or
swingers in Hollywood and you showed
them your wga card Drew Carrey picked up
the tab for your meal
however often you went in there if you
went for breakfast lunch and dinner with
your WJ card it was free you didn't tip
he didn't pay anything and it all went
to Drew carre's tab he did it in the
20072 2008 strike he did it for this
strike for 148 days if you're a guild
member you could eat for free which for
a lot of people who were on this the
sort of cutting edge of poverty like
food is a big [__] deal and you know
like that's
nobody has to do that but that's that
was his way that's really awesome man
yeah that was his way of supporting the
strike he's like I'm not walking I still
got to do prices right
but writers eat for free while we're on
Strike wow that was very very cool yeah
you know and I got I went to swingers
once um which isn't on like Fairfax and
Lena I think it is um swingers kids if
you've ever been
if you've never been to Los Angeles and
if you remember independent film of the
90s and whatnot there was a motion
picture uh with a guy named John favro
never amounted to much uh and Vince
vaugh and that was called swingers and
in swingers they're at a
cafe oddly tell oddly enough it's not
swingers swingers didn't take place at
swingers it took place at the cafe 101
which is now changed names and but uh
swingers which is like a diner in Los
Angeles on was it
Melrose Fairfax I
think I mean the it's on Beverly Beverly
Beverly there it is they have a they
have a vegan menu as well um it's like
pure Jersey diner but done Los Angeles
style very hipster and stuff was very
popular it Still Remains popular but
like was you know
in the
a I I think that was when it Rose to
prominence that was a ha that's not a
cheap restaurant either I mean they're
not like overpriced but like to pick up
a bunch of people's breakfast lunch or
dinner over the course of that long ass
strike like J Carrey got it rich man I
mean Price is Right is no [__] joke
the J carry show was fing joke like done
extraordinarily well for himself and and
that that's his version of of paying it
back and I was in singers once and you
know I walked out with a with a group of
friends and Drew Cary was just sitting
at the counter like doing the crossw
word puzzle just hanging out so we got
to [__] thank Drew Cary for buying us
lunch and for buying hundred you know
whatever 16,000 people he picked up the
lunch tabs if they wanted to go which is
beautiful it's really cool man that
makes me like it's not like I was like I
had no respect for Drew Carrey but that
[__] makes me respect the [__] out of
Drew
Carrey um somebody in the chat says I
heard it total totaled around
$750,000 with both Bob's Big Boy and
swingers I mean I I I don't know how
much it did but I I would I would maybe
even guess a bit more because that's a
long time there was a lot of riders the
place was packed every time I was in
there Espinosa 1989 and shat say Hey
Kevin as a theater owner because as we
all know I own SM Castle Cinemas um in
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey go to
sm.com right now for tickets what are
your thoughts on the teror Swift ays
tour movie deal with AMC do you know
about this I do what is I know we're get
we're not an AMC theater but I know we
are getting that Taylor Swift movie it's
mod Castle yeah it's the Taylor Swift to
be followed by Beyonce um went to a
handful of movie studios the universal
was her first stop and said I shot this
concert that I had just been on you know
the one that's made you know hundreds
and hundreds if not billions of dollar
literally a billion dollars that tour
made a billion dollars yeah and I was
like hey I shot it it's it's cut it's
ready to go do you want to distribute it
and the the the terms that the studios
gave her were awful and her father who's
apparently a lawyer and I think maybe
her businessman manager was like don't
take that deal like go straight to the
[__] Distributors and so they went
Toc and made apparently an incredibly
favorable deal for Taylor and Company um
and they've already had $100 million in
pre-sales um and I think they then since
decided to they either found a
distributor or were dealing with chains
directly other than AMC so that other
theaters like smart Castle cemas in
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey can get a
hold of it but and then Beyonce did the
same thing like she went straight to the
to the she's four Walling it except you
know directly to 4,500 screens um but
Sid stepping the Distributors and just
getting all of that money Sid stepping
the Distributors what a [__] crazy
original idea I I just so mad I never
thought about doing that myself I'm
flabbergasted I just wish I had
something as successful to sell [__] um
you know me I've long believed in the
[__] the middle dick process um and I
like taking my movies out on tour myself
so like red State Jane sbob super groovy
cartoon movie yoga
hosers Jane Sil Bob reboot clerks 3 um
these are movies that I also
bypassed distribution traditional
distribution um but man oh man like what
[__] studio is dumb enough to [__]
her over like that's free money yeah she
shot she came to you with finished
product man you could have just been
like yeah all right it's an acquisition
and here we go but she you know their
unscrupulous Behavior forced her to find
a [__] workaround and yeah now she's
gonna make even more
money how make more than a billion
dollars on a [__] billion dollar tour
well you do motion picture release
they're talking about this thing's going
to open $125 $150 million I mean it's
already pre-sold $100 million worth of
tickets like and I think I think
Beyonce's Renaissance tour is only even
going to play Friday Saturday and Sunday
nights or not even a doom midweek so
smart man like use a movie theater you
know for a bunch of types
of entertainment you know it's like it's
the fathom stuff
this may Usher the return of the concert
movie I mean I mean between these
between these two flicks and stop making
sense like [__] literally charting in
the top 10 as an 24 re-release by just
playing on a bunch of IMAX screens I
think so at this point that's that's a
huge story as far as I'm concerned this
movie is older than [__] sin man came
out in like what 86
87 and you know not only is it reunited
to talking [__] heads but it's
earning serious dollars at the box
office Nostalgia is a hell of a drug man
could be the thing that saves Cinema's
music go figure who would have think it
who would have think it um so yes the
writers the writer strike is over
writers are back to work um the actor
strike continues and you know I've still
been out on the picking line for a
little bit to support the actors because
when they came out for us it was a huge
deal and so so long as I'm not in a
writer's room and not otherwise
preoccupied then I'll be on the line
like actors are [__]
great are cool they smell good they they
look good sing songs they're famous
man be around famous people and [__]
that's why we're in this business we
like to be around famous
[Laughter]
people you too can be around famous
people I need
guideliner you and me got start wearing
guideliner just one layer right just a
little bit of a you GNA look like the
the mayor of Gotham
City yes as a matter of fact do that's
what I was thinking of I was like you
know what I want I would look like as
the mayor of Gotham City Mr
carbonal um let us uh talk about um
things that we have seen indeed let us I
I hesitate to use the term review Mark
but let us recap some things that we
have seen indeed I've seen some things
may I go first please do moments before
this program
began and this is my
Fitbit my fancy Fitbit I've got the most
basic Fitbit when we were in Sierra 2
some and I was in The Nut House This Is
How They track you like where so you
didn't know what the [__] time it was or
anything like that right so the only way
you knew what time it was by was by the
Fitbit and that's also how they tracked
you they had us all on a [__]
computer so they could see where you
were and [__] like that but that was
when I also fell in love with the idea
of like step counting and [__] SP I've
never been a watch guy but now ever
since the booby hatch I've been wearing
a [__] Fitbit it's very Logan's
Run right it is very Logan's Run and so
I said when I was in there I was like
this place is like run like you're crazy
I was like that's why I'm in the booby
hge the i i extended it out there not to
show off the lowest end Fitbit there is
Mark but to mind the looking at time
because moments before this show
began I was in that room right over
there watching
Loki I I watched Loki ep season two
episode one kids it's now available on
Disney Plus
um just as of 6 pm
tonight
Pacific uh and uh 9 o'clock I guess
Eastern that would stand a reason uh you
too could be a part of the Loki magic
join the
TBA um good you know yeah good stuff I
like him here's my one beef has nothing
to do with the show you see these
Billboards of him around
town you think he I think he looks
incredibly old in those
pictures and I thought maybe it had
something to do with the plot but I just
think it's a poor choice of photo
because he's not that old man he's still
like young and vital when you watch the
show um but man those Billboards like
they make him look like a little old man
I felt like they're all over 10 some of
them some of them I haven't seen a l i
couldn't you know go down the line and
pick and choose but I've seen a couple
that look like they were generated by
AI which is also like guys read the room
like yeah they're still they're not
still doing that [__] after secret
Invasion are they I mean I don't know
man I don't know
um yeah that's the yeah hey bman you
noticed this at all so uh one of my
trivia questions for trivia last night
was actually a
expert um graphic designer went on
Twitter and deconstructed the Lo some of
the Loki posters and pointed back to the
images that the AI used to generate
parts of the poster so yeah it's another
it is a very big uh controversy right
now that Marvel again used AI to promote
their
stuff so that billboard picture of Tom
Heston is AI they're saying that it
elements of the poster or AI so she she
didn't say it's the entire poster but
she was able to point out very specific
elements of specifically the poster that
has like the winding path around him it
is at least in part AI
generated like like guys your Marvel
Comics yeah why yeah and again like
didn't they take enough sh did off of
secret invasions opening
credits there's enough time to turn the
ship um weird in any of but you enjoyed
it though I did I had a good time um I
think it's a well-made show it's
very I'm it's I I
don't I it feels like one of the
influences of this show is Brazil
a little bit no I mean first season
definitely had that like the
mundanity of this Fantastical thing it's
like there's F cabinets and office
spaces and people are bored and just
going through the motions of doing
remarkable things bureaucracy in the
midst of something magical yeah yeah
yeah 100% like look at all his red tape
about doing the
Fantastic um he
KIU
Kuan
wonderful uh but brand new I mean the
show it was very fast really tough to
get a beat on where the season's going
he's glitching they don't call it that
though right
time slipping or something they call it
um but he's Charming Man and you know I
was sitting there watching tonight going
this guy is [__] he been playing Loki
as long as [__] [__] Kelsey gramar
been playing Frasier man feels like he's
been doing it I mean seriously since
[__] Thor since the very first Thor
right yeah which is gotta be more than
10 years ago right I think 15 feels was
10 years it was 10 years at did 15 for
Iron Man right right and so Thor
was within two three years yeah 2011 so
12 years
ago yeah that's
it yeah with a gun in my head I would
have said like oh no Tom hson been in
our world he's been Loki for like nearly
years when you make like 30 some odd
movies in 15 years and also that [__]
billboard ain't helping makes it look
like he's been playing Loki for a
hundred [__] years that Capt captures
my imagination every time I drive
through town I look up and I'm like who
[__] O Okay
that um unless it's part of the plot
which I don't think so uh in any event
uh definitely you know I'm in um I I
didn't make it past episode three of
secret Invasion I know what
happened um and I watched the big fight
but so I think I'll I think I'll
probably be into this show I like the
first one quite a bit
yeah like some reason I hope it brings
people back for him too because it seems
like people jumping off those Disney
Plus
shows I mean I was about to say like
it's secret invasion was the first
Marvel thing that I didn't finish yeah
um you know just didn't feel motivated
it became obligatory and I was like I
don't have to finish this I'm not
enjoying myself very much so maybe I'll
just stop you know what it'll be okay if
I stop
you know and and it's it's a weird thing
to to encounter that level of apathy
towards something that you used to
be 100% po committed
for
um they
uh they they they're they're uh they're
committed still to King it seems
like I mean I
guess uh I'll say
for this episode though uh especially I
I appreciate as a guy who spent the last
month trying to recreate
1986 which you know you really start to
go like
[__] um any other movie I've ever made
man you turn the camera on whatever it
sees in the background it's fine because
everything I've ever done is
set in the present you do a period piece
every time you turn the camera on you
got to make
sure that anything in line in view with
the camera
ain't past
1986 otherwise it runs the risk of
taking people out of the
picture so our movie is not like hey man
Pac-Man hey man AR Rubik's Cube you
know hey Cabbage Patch Kids it's not
like a series of 80s [__] iconic
Wonder Woman 84 no it really isn't and
yet somehow it captures
1986 and not because we're brilliant but
because anywhere we put the camera we
made sure that nothing in the line of
sight was past
86 so it's all a long way of saying it's
hard to make a [__] period piece hard
to make something
look old or it look like it did when it
was you know
vital unless you've got Loki money
because they created 1982 McDonald's at
the end of this
episode that [__] blew my mind like
clearly they're in bed with the
McDonald's people right because there's
been like some sort of Loki campaign or
there's some sort of Happ deal or
whatever the
[__]
this this McDonald's that is walked into
at the end of this
episode
spellbindingly accurate to the
era
spellbinding to the point where that's
like I didn't I don't know what the [__]
happened in the scene I was just like
this now that's that's a period piece
with money right there man like that
[__] looked like a McDonald's in 1982
it was [__] really like I that more
than anything else that [__] did it
for me where I was like
wow I can smell the mcdl te from here
and the guy goes do you want to try our
chicken McNuggets they're new and I was
like new in
1982 um yeah so I watch Loki and uh
Loki's uh We're Off to the Races worth
watching I haven't seen it yet but I'm
gonna dig into it probably tomorrow
night or tomorrow day I can do whatever
I
want you yeah [__] [__] he you
Canen well not So Much Anymore sooner or
later you're going to go back to work
right I know well I'm still I still got
[__] to write um which is uh which is
keeping me busy but I'm on my own time
so still got [__] to write the mark
Bernardin
story it's like all these
words um what have you seen you saw
ahoka right I've seen Ahsoka which you
know have you seen any of Ahsoka yet or
no I saw episode
one okay um well you know me and bath
man can go deep on Ahsoka in a little
bit I saw sounds so [__] filthy I'm
gonna go
deep I saw the
Creator what' you think I saw I watched
about an hour of it at the SM Castle
last
week um I I think it's it's it's an
ambitious but flawed
movie um I think that it's I mean it
like hey if you like if you're a big fan
of the story uh uh sort of plot device
of here's a rled older Warrior guy who's
lost his Hope For Humanity who after
encountering a young child who might be
full of magic they go on a world
traveling Odyssey for him to escort her
slash him to a place that will do like
it's it's Lone Wolf and Cub it's Last of
Us it's the Mandalorian it's every
version of that story that you've ever
seen before um some of the World
building is incredibly interesting some
of it is incredibly lazy
um it's the hey what if what if we
treated robots like they were humans but
also made them like
sleep so you have your hero having to
sneak into a a room of a bunch of robots
napping like why are robots napping why
explain this to me how does this work
why are their eyes closed why why why
are they why do you have to be quiet
like what is why like it's a lot of
things we thought might be cool but
don't actually Bear any scrutiny
whatsoever right right um you know and I
think that like the ending did not work
for me uh I won't spoil it because hey
if you're still interested in you're G
to go but it it did look gorgeous like
they did spend some money on it and more
like used a lot of Ingenuity to make it
kind of happen like apparently they shot
the whole movie on like a a $33,000 Sony
digital camera that uh that seems to
have been phenomenal looking at the way
you could capture low light the way you
can capture motion the way you can
capture all that that stuff kind of on
the Fly um some of the the literally VFX
rendering of [__] is phenomenal um but
as a story it didn't quite hold for me
um Denzel's boy is good but Denzel's boy
is always good John David
Washington um but yeah so that I I will
throw some hosas to the finale of
reservation dogs which I think I've
talked about before you have you've very
positively spoken about it before yeah
it very very link later it's very just
like we're making Indie stories you know
about these four kids on a on a
reservation in Oklahoma um it it it had
its series finale last week and it was
beautiful I mean the last two episodes
of that show are among the best episodes
of any TV show I've ever seen um it's
it's it's astounding astounding work so
if you have not seen all on on
Hulu just strap in like it's it's
probably a week's worth of a binge if
you're if you're in the mood for it but
so [__] good electric Eliminator five
in chat corrected You by saying hey man
small wond slept
too yeah that's the rigor we're gonna
hold this robot that's the bar is this
Wonder
test B I would also I would also be
remiss if I didn't mention that C3PO
takes a nap in A New Hope
he does he says like if you need me sir
I'll be powering down he's like go ahead
and he [__] knocks out yeah he's like
oh I don't want to listen to this old
man speak about lights you know what
Mark [__] you [__] our phones go to
sleep why the [__] wouldn't a robot go
to
sleep does it do our phones lay in
little
hammock that would be adorable oh that
would be adorable does my phone have
legs
just don't be so loud the phone is
sleeping um I uh I I watched like I said
about I got to maybe not even an hour uh
part of the movie where it's like the
child and uh I thought like once again
who was the director is Gareth Edwards
yeah we did Rogue one he did Rogue one
prior to that also did
Godzilla yes first of the new phrase did
that movie Monsters
right yeah that's map is he went to like
like a place where a hurricane had just
destroyed an area and then shot all this
footage he was like the monsters have
come through here and then only had to
deliver big special effects toward the
end of the
picture that's how he got the Godzilla
job because they were like give this guy
[__] Godzilla and Godzilla the big
complaint about that movie when it came
out was like remember they were they're
like oh here he is he's about to fight
and they got these two doors closed
cling just as the fight's about to begin
and then it's like oh I see we keep the
budget down by not showing the monster
very much yeah I remember my son at the
time must have been like 12 was like is
there any Godzilla in the Godzilla movie
yeah know then this this cat directed
Rogue one and everybody loves Rogue one
and whether or not you you know are like
hey man [__] you know Tony Gilroy did
the Darth Vader [__] whatever [__] like
that's you know this my point is this
kid knows what to do with a camera right
he garyth is no [__] slouch true
direct through and through and he did he
did during this sort of press cycle for
for Creator he was like listen like I've
been quiet because who doesn't love
getting to have made a Star Wars movie
I'm very proud of that movie he's like
but I was there for like the shooting of
every frame of that movie he's like I
was like it's like I shot the Darth
Vader
like Tony gy was there he 100% did some
great work and helping us get over the
finish line but the the narrative that I
was replaced um is is a false narrative
I like hey man good for you stand up for
yourself yeah
really
um okay uh res dogs brick something says
res dogs is beautiful so you got a
little backup there no it's it's
astonishing um there's there's always an
episode or two each season that I just
look at and go holy [__] like I didn't I
didn't know you could do that on TV um I
didn't know you could just swing so hard
for emotion and then landed um to the
point where I'm all [__] teary and
weepy and my face is all wet and like
didn't see that comeing at all um so by
all means if you if you have the time
and you have the talent and the
opportunity watch yourself some red dogs
Ian Carol in chat says Children of Men
is hands down my favorite escort Mission
flip
um that was an escort Mission flick but
tactics says ET is clearly the best
escort mission of all
time which is true that's an escort
Mission I I did see some dude in the
chat was like my favorite escort movie
Pretty Woman yes the ultimate escort
movie
$33,000 change your life Welcome to
Hollywood what's your
dream send a [__] Relic um some
people in chat been asking us if we
watch Gen 5 did you watch it I didn't I
H have not seen yet no I also have not
seen it yet um uh the
bear still love it still love it I've
met a few more people who Echo your
thoughts
exactly um I W I got my wife to sit down
and watch both SP uh Spider-Man's
cartoon
movies spiderverse and across the
spiderverse back to back oh did she like
him [__] her I loved
him like I never watched him back to
back that was [__] phenomenal but she
did she really she she was blown away by
those movies she's like they are [__]
gorgeous I was like right um but but
yeah I I hadn't gotten a chance to like
ever watch one and then the other that
what a what a great experience it was
guys Lord Miller cats and those
directors
Jeff as we say on the show all right man
do
Ahsoka uh well I'm gonna need I need a
BFF man to talk about Ahsoka BFF man get
your in here
B bman is not only gonna talk about
Ahsoka with Mark uh Ban's gonna talk
about something else later on man coming
up soon it is we got we got a Star Wars
twer um he went deep into Star Wars land
he's going to tell you something about
it mean
I'll give you a hint I loved one of
them oh well I know the one that you
[__] loved you won't stop talking
about so clearly it's not
Ahsoka um I I I
mean we all know how much I love Ros
Ariel Dawson I thought she's wonderful
as Ahsoka uh but episode one felt
very long to me now you know of course
I'm a student of the internet so I know
episode five is where a lot of people
feel like it kicks in and becomes the
show it's meant to be and stuff but uh
episode one was was long and and not bad
but just long and uh it I figured like
you know I'll wait for the rest of these
to gather up before I finish watching so
I kind of fell off at one there's a
there's a lot of air in the show there's
a lot of like hey if we cut this a bit
tighter it can move a bit faster and we
can get to where we're
going do you think that's all about
because those shows
are not I don't think of them as
Airy not generally yeah there's lot of
air like there's the the six minutes
where she's she's like swiveling the
tops of rods she's in the map room at
Tannis and she's just doing this thing
and it's taking a long very long it's so
funny you reference that scene because
that remember that the first time as I
was watching I was like is she still
working is she literally going to go to
all three
pillars like yeah they're not going to
Quick cut it it's not like what it
seemed like they were getting paid by
the
minute you know what I'm saying like it
was just like they're like let's string
this [__] out normally pretty tight
efficient storytelling but there was a
lot of lot of like weird visual
expository stuff that felt like it could
have been trimmed yeah I mean it does it
it has the feel of a we have to hit a
certain runtime and we didn't have
enough story so just like leave it all
in let's not cut anything for time um
but I think that that over the course of
the show and we we talked about you know
JC I my general feelings about it which
were um not having any knowledge
whatsoever of rebels and only having a
sort of passing familiarity with with
the Clone Wars this show did not welcome
me in as somebody who does not know who
these characters are um I don't know who
Ezra Bridger is except all I get is that
everybody wants him back I do not know
who thrawn is except I get that nobody
wants him back but the show never
explains to me why it doesn't really
explain the relationship between any of
the characters on screen like I don't
really know what Sabine and Hera and and
Ahsoka how their Dynamic works because
so much of the show plays it in the same
kind of stoic monotone so I never never
got a sense of what those characters
meant to each other other than they knew
each other I don't know how they left it
the last time they spoke I don't there's
no energetic charge when they show up
again like it just kind of it exists at
this sort of steady three and it never
spikes at any point um and and getting
to the end of the show and like yes
episode five half of it is phenomenal
because you get Anakin Skywalker you get
Clone Wars you get young Ahsoka you get
the feeling of what Darth Vader would
have been had he not lost a fight to
Obi-Wan Kenobi you get the feeling of oh
this is who Vader was supposed to be
this is the Anakin that that has all of
its faculties that isn't breathing
through a tube that can [__] kick ass
and that's really interesting it's so
what if Star Wars It's what if he didn't
lose what if he did what if The High
Ground didn't matter is what that is and
it's great but then you have another
half of an episode episode where it's
people wondering if ahsoka's alive or
dead I like she's alive guys we know
she's alive the show's called Ahsoka
like you cannot build tension out of a
thing that has no tension um and without
tension why are we in any of these
scenes and by the time you get to sit go
ahead I was just going to say to Echo
that it's almost as if the main
characters in the show all know they're
the main characters in the show and
nothing can happen to them so they're
not I mean it was like the best
space battle we've seen since Return of
the
Jedi where everybody was like well I
guess our Shields are down isn't that
important isn't that no we're the main
characters it's cool like there's no
urgency in any of the characters about
the stakes of what's
Happening no everybody's got plot armor
so nothing matters um and nothing
matters even emotionally like by the
time you get to the finale um which you
know is fine but guess what guys Thon
has returned because of course he did um
we found Ezra Bridger because of course
we were going to um but there's no
emotional response to anybody's part
about these things happening I still
don't know why thraw is so bad and he's
been in three episodes of this show and
I don't get it I don't get what makes
Ezra Bridger different from every other
[__] Jedi I've ever seen other than
it's got a pretty cool beard and seems a
little happier than everybody else but
why am I supposed to care other than
that you tell me I am um and and and the
urgency is so weird like there's there's
a scene in in the finale where all three
of your leads are back together again
right like Ahsoka traveled through space
whales and and Sabine lied to people and
gave away the bad guy globe and all the
things but they all found Ezra Bridger
and it's like hey great okay what should
we do now let's just [__] hang out
with these Turtle creatures and drive
this spaceship as slow as we possibly go
to Nowhere as opposed to should we go do
with the bad guy who we know is here no
no not until we have to there's
also uh a weird conversation so the
backstory is is that Ezra saved the
Galaxy by disappearing with grand
Emerald Thon the end of rebels
and they found this kid for the first
time he was what 10 years old 11 years
old when he disappeared he's now a
22-year-old man in that age group and
there's a scene where Sabine is catching
him up like this guy sacrificed his life
for the rebellion and disappeared before
it even started essentially and saine
like yeah the rebels won the Imperials
they blew up the Death Star the Battle
of Endor and Ezra's like oh that's
cool as like she's telling the story to
Ezra and he's responding the way that
like we would respond because we've seen
Return of the Jedi for the last 40 years
but this is a guy who gave up everything
so that the rebels would have like the
smallest chance of success and his
response is oh that's cool I can't mhm
that that's great that's great the good
guys won not like oh my god it worked I
My Sacrifice was not for not I've I'm
I'm still a a virgin living with space
turtles in a space where I'm eating
straw for the last 10 years and it's all
been worth it because we won he's just
like
cool yeah there is no emotional
connection to anything I don't know what
Ahsoka story is in the first season I
don't know what whatever she went
through says about her I don't know what
her Quest was other than to find Ezra
which she kind of does but Sabine does
it first like what's her win by the end
of that season and it doesn't have to be
a plot win because she can lose like
Luke can lose in Empire in Empire
Strikes Back but I know what his Arc was
I know what he wanted to do and I know
how he failed at doing it I don't know
very much about what Ahsoka was up to
for a
for whom this show is named I don't know
what she's doing I don't know what
Ezra's story is other than waving around
like hanging out with space Turtles and
now his friends are back okay do you
have something to tell these friends
were you keeping it secret like was
there something that they don't know
that they need to know
like anything to hold on to and uh and
and so the show doesn't have it was what
does anybody know what the viewership
has been the ratings
so that was um an interesting thing
because uh Forbes releases their
estimated streaming numbers and they
said Ahsoka the premiere of Ahsoka
Forbes said did like 1.2 million which
is not great it's about what Andor did
um and everybody was like Andor tanked
um then about 3 hours later Lucas film
goes 14 million people watched the
premiere of
Ahsoka so one of them is
wrong right well I mean that's the
tricky thing about the the uh the
somewhat impenetrability of streaming
numbers which is Forbes like they have
one metric and I think there's some
company maybe called Bamba or Namba or
something like that not Namba different
company yeah I don't know different
organization but uh but there is one
resource to report streaming numbers but
it's very scattershot it doesn't wrap
its arms around every person who's
watching but much like HBO used to do
they'll release numbers when it's
advantageous for them to release numbers
like how many people watch Game of
Thrones HBO would tell you every week
did we know how many people watched
Generation Kill no they didn't give a
[__] about telling us about that because
it didn't matter and so when Disney plus
decides to release numbers it's because
they did good and yeah they have all of
them and they can say or but or like the
Forbes was 1.2 million households and
Disney's number was 14 million people so
to me I was just like oh they they just
think 12 people live in each household
is is kind of how it felt to me because
like you know Netflix releases like
minutes watched as opposed to people
watch um which is a completely different
metric and those minutes don't have to
be that they finished it or they'll even
say oh no we had like 40 million people
finish watching squid game but lots of
other people started watching Bridgton
we don't know if they finished or not
like it's it's still the Wild West in
terms of reporting viewership numbers
but I mean I just I came away from the
season wondering like so this is the
thing we're going to lead into other
movies about this is the the pillar upon
which we are now building the rest of
the Star Wars Universe um and it feels
weak it feels it feels a little shaky
and like yeah Rosario's always good like
she's always good even when all she has
to do is stand there and cross her arms
and kind of like gently smile at
something she remembers that we don't
know um but the show itself just doesn't
have a lot it doesn't have a lot of of
of spine to it it doesn't have a lot of
throw to it um and it's sad because
they're they every resource at sort of
Disney and Lucas home's disposal is
being lobed at this and uh and it it's
not it's not paying off n not for me it
it feels
like kind of a second tier Star Wars
novel turned into a movie or turned into
a TV show like it doesn't feel it kind
of I mean to some degree isn't it like
it's air to the Empire a little bit if
they're bringing in yeah but it's not as
compelling as air to the
Empire like they've done some cool stuff
like spoilers it's up they do in air to
the Empire uh thrawn
brings back cloning and when that book
came out in 1991 nobody had seen cloning
in Star Wars so that was a big deal
thraw was going to retake the Galaxy
using a clone army well we've seen clone
armies multiple times in Star Wars now
and so what they did in Ahsoka is they
used nightsister Force magic and created
a a zombie army so anybody who dies as a
stormtrooper is now able to come back
and fight the way a clone would and
that's how Thon is going to retake and I
thought that was kind of a cool take and
parallel to air to the Empire in a world
where you can't lift it directly because
we've already seen Clone Wars um you
know using using zombie Troopers which
uh were also wildly successful books um
written back in the day I thought that
was neat But ultimately like all your
main characters seem as bored with the
show as the people watching it
are yeah like they're never
scary you know and
like say what you want about the last
couple seasons of Game of Thrones but
when you get to hard home and when you
get to the [__] zombie White Walkers
that never die like that [__] is [__]
terrifying yes like like when they get a
zombie [__] Dragon like breathing
blue fire like ohly like what the [__]
is happening here this just felt like it
didn't it didn't bother the characters
um kind of at all that one of them were
like they're dead now they're dead now
you know
yeah you know because everybody has to
survive like you never got to lose
anyone um yeah it is just you know super
easy barely inconvenience for them to do
all the things they needed to
do and then the [__] that pissed me off
the most I'll just tell you there's a
bit at the end of the of the of the
episode where like Ezra on [__]
thrawn's you know [__] Imperial
Command Ship as he's pulling away and
saine decides to stay and rescue [__]
uh Ahsoka and you're like oh no the
friends are separated and know what's
going to happen to him he's stuck on
thrown Ship by himself and then they cut
to a to a tidan [__] ship Landing in
Hera's joint and [__] Ezra steps out
dress as a stormtrooper it's like hey
how's it going like what the [__] like
what happened on that [__] like
apparently it was no problem for you to
survive at all steal a ship get home
hang out with Hera like where's
everybody else like I just you can't
Gallop over time like that as if it
didn't happen you can't pretend as if
everything is as easy needs to be except
that was the show where everything was
fine all the time for everybody also
like first off he's going from a
different galaxy to this other Galaxy so
they were ostensibly in hyperspace for a
long time he's the only one on that ship
and he kept that storm trooper armor on
the entire
time to to to pull the gag at the end
like it like even in a new hope those
guys take that armor off the second they
can take it off you know Han and Luke
the moment they they get to cellblock
uh uh AA 23 like those helmets are off
and they don't go back
on Ezra wore it the whole time and I
know it's nitpicky but it's just
silly it's just silly you know and it's
just because they thought it was a cool
reveal for him to be there it's like
how'd you make it here oh somehow Ezra
returned
and that's all you need yeah dude that
look we're gonna talk about trilogies
let's talk about the only Trilogy that
[__] matters the clerk's Trilogy my
friends um somebody asked me in chat uh
F kusuma said Kevin why aren't you
talking about the new Clerk's Trilogy
box set on Blu-ray looks cool I will
talk about it because all three of us
involved in this here's show also had an
involvement in one of the clerk's
pictures Mark was in Clerk's 3 for
heaven sakes I was I I have a voice
cameo in clerks 3 scum yeah as the scum
and villain um throw up an image from
the I just texted you that image um
Amazon I think is it an Amazon
exclusive uh that's the link yeah I
think it's an Amazon exclusive they're
doing this Clerk's Trilogy box set look
at that it's all three clerks movies in
one big box set and the Box looks like
the front of the
stores and it's got stickers and [__]
put you know [__] all over the and
then on the back there's a slot for like
where you'd stick your VHS overnight
like if you were droing off we didn't
have one of those at quick Stu but I
didn't want to fight him on this because
I thought was clever that's where the
DVD slip case goes man but that's coming
out November 7th
kids all the [__] clerks is you could
shake a goddamn stick at in one
beautiful box set from the good Folks at
Lions Gate and
Amazon um okay bman get in here and
[__] tell us a story about going to
outer space son he's cboy so uh last
Tuesday I guess a week ago Tuesday eight
or days ago Tuesday uh I entered outer
space on the galactic star
Cruiser and
uh to not bury the lead it was one of
the greatest experiences of my whole
life and I had uh when they said I was
always intended to go when they said
they were going to close I uh called I
called some people who I know are
connected there and pulled whatever
strings I could to get on I was on the
second to last voyage that it ever did
um but it very much felt like the last
Voyage Because the actual last Voyage as
I understand it had been basically sold
out before they announced it was going
to close because it was one of the
weekend
voyages um so for my Voyage was the last
voyage that the people who had been on
this before and loved
it went
on so we had three 365 people I would
say probably 225 of them came in Cosplay
stayed in Cosplay the entire time um and
had characters and just went all in uh
My Hope in dream for this was
that the immersion would be so good that
for a few moments I would feel like the
9-year-old boy who dis redis discovered
his Star Wars action figures with the
person who would soon become his best
friend because we both love playing Star
Wars action figures way past the point
where other kids thought that was AC an
acceptable age to do it um and what's
crazy is is that I didn't feel that but
what I got was almost better in that it
was
um they sold it as a Star Wars hotel and
it was not a hotel it was it was like
the best parts of the best escape
room liveaction role play dinner
theater and like team building Excursion
you could ever
imagine um and because everybody was
playing a part and playing a role
everybody was kind of open and
vulnerable in the way that like actors
are when they're playing a part so
everybody you interacted with
immediately became like your best friend
nobody was on their phone the whole time
like it was all about like being there
in that moment and like my kind of
takeaway from the whole thing
was like it like I came back and Jen
split she's like okay you had your trip
I'm going to the Pacific Northwest for a
week have fun being stay-at-home dad um
but what I found is like because I
played in outer space for 45 hours when
Jon's like let's play house
I'm like it like reawakened my
imagination in a way that like Co and
talking over a device for the last 15
years kind of Walled in um so like I had
the second best time of my life playing
with my kid coming off the star Cruiser
cuz it like retaught me how
to open up my imagination in a way that
I'm sure people who play D and D every
week kind of get a taste of um but it
was super intense that way like
everybody when they were leaving was
crying
um and what's cool is like the the story
starts in the same place every time and
it ends in the same place every time but
everything in the middle
is dictated by the choices the customers
the passengers make while they're there
and all of the actors are improving
nonstop basically you're you're on it
for 45 hours so I was the second person
to check in at 1:00 on Tuesday and I was
the last person to check out at 10:00
a.m. on Thursday and for that whole time
everybody who is an employee of Disney
is is in character the whole time if I'm
like oh hey where are you from they're
like oh Mustafar yeah don't I don't talk
about it you know it was
um it
was insanely cool and it's all gone
it's yeah
yeah I mean there was stuff like um
first off because you're there and I
I'll spoil the end like uh Rey shows up
towards the end of the second day
and you have to help Rey finish she's
kind of like the superhero that comes in
and finishes the mission that you
started um if you're on the Jedi Mission
and uh and like for the first time I
like gave a [__] about Rey as a
character and like she shows up up and
she's like you guys I know you're just
passengers trying to enjoy this Star
cruise but I can't do this without your
help and I'm like oh my God Rey's asking
for somebody's help for the first time
she can't do it all by
herself that's character growth that's
an arc yeah it was so like even the fact
that
like I have been slightly vocal about my
dislike of the sequel trilogy um and
I've hidden how I really really feel
about it deep down so I don't get
crucified on the internet like I liked
Ray and kylo ren on the ship because
like the story that we were all telling
when it hit the big kind of dinner
theater finale you were invested in in
the what they were selling on that it
was amazing I you know there was one
point where they have about six
different storylines so they have the
ship captain the ship entertainment
director The
Smuggler story scoundrel Story the Jedi
story and uh the first order story and I
was pretty close to being Smuggler the
whole time but I did a lot of the Jedi
and a lot of the um ship captain who was
like uh resistance like good guy and um
there was a
lull in my Smuggler missions and I was
just s oh and then there was one other
guy that is like he's kind of like The
Lovable loser like the goofy or the jar
jar where he's like it's my first day on
the job and he keeps [__] up
throughout the course like he
accidentally turns chewbaca over to the
Imperials and gives the Droid with the
plans to the Imperials and
um he kind of takes a turn at one point
and he's like I'm going to stand up for
what's right and there's a point where
he recruits all these actors are trying
to recruit you to be in their mission
path um and I had finished The Smuggler
stuff and I was sitting in the lobby and
this lovable loser guy comes up to me
and he's like hey you want to help me
steal a
ship and I guess he had recruited like
20 or 30 other
passengers and none of them showed up to
do the ship stealing Mission which is
essentially like the bridge of the ship
has all of these like essentially arcade
stations where it's either like you're
using the tractor beam or you're doing
the shields or you're shooting Tie
fighters and so you're supposed to have
like 20 or 30 things but on my trip
everybody wanted to be a Smuggler so
nobody showed up for this guy's Mission
so he comes so two people of the 20
people who said they were going to be
there were actually showed up so this
actor has to improv he runs out to the
lobby I'm just sitting there drinking a
glass of water he's like you want to
help me steal a ship so he gets like the
six of us that are sitting in the lobby
so now
there's should be 20 people there's
eight of us doing the job of 20 people
and he's standing at the ship Council
barking order shoot the Tie Fighter do
this thing do that thing we capture the
Tie Fighter we get the plans we send him
to the resistance and then during the
big
finale he gets taken away by the first
order and as he's getting dragged away
he gives his big Rah R speech and the
big Rah R speech typically would be like
you know these passengers are just here
for a good time and they showed up and
they helped me capture this TIE fighter
which saved the day but the speech this
time
was I got commitments from 30 of these
people and none of them showed up to do
the right thing and I'm sick and tired
of people in this galaxy not doing the
right thing and I've had it and I'm
going to stand up for what's right and
these six people who showed up for me
when nobody else did they're the type of
people we need running this Galaxy and
they're just here not to shoot Tie
fighters but to have a good time and
like all of a sudden there's 30 people
who are getting shamed for going and
like watching Yoda show up and the Jedi
room and not going doing this guy's
thing and I'm like in tears cuz I'm like
that's right I am a good guy I am making
a
difference so it's like you know that
type of thing that happens here that
involves you and invests you in the
story in a way of like you know you
watch Clerk's 3 and a lot of people cry
at the end of clerk's 3 and that's you
telling a story manipulating them
with the hope that somehow what you're
saying is universal enough that they can
attach their experience to that that
thing as a
Storyteller this was almost like the
next like evolution of Storytelling in
that like I wasn't reacting to the fact
that like oh I've known people who've
died and this is really heartbreaking to
me and I've watched these clerks
characters I literally made a decision
that saved the [__]
Galaxy you know so like emotionally like
it's you suckered people in like in in a
Choose Your Own Adventure novel I I I
came back and I just felt like
since the pandemic I uh when I go to
scum and villainy at night I like kind
of say hi to the people I know and then
I go and I hide in the office and I
watch what's happening on the security
cameras cuz I'm like oh this is too much
this is too much and what I found since
coming back is the sense of community
for those 45 hours was
so strong
that like I find myself wanting to go to
scum and villainy and just hang out and
talk to people I don't know again and so
like for
me and like it wasn't lifechanging in
that like I was depressed enough I'm not
depressed or anything like that but like
it feels like I got a little bit of like
what it means to be a human being in
like the age of devices back uh and and
I don't think it was an accident like I
don't think that Disney didn't know what
they were doing there um I think they
just didn't know how to sell it or price
it the right way uh cuz not and not a
single s person who went that I have
seen online or anything was like that
wasn't worth the money the only people
were saying it wasn't worth the money or
the people who didn't go cuz they're
like $5,000 a knife for hotel that has
no [__] Windows no way uh it was Ted
Ted B our friend and boss over at
Netflix um from uh the Masters of the
Universe stuff we do he went you know
months ago
and he said the same thing he was
like it's once in A- lifetime experience
the immersion of it was magical
Whimsical it's crazy that they couldn't
make this work man like Disney is
awesome at selling many expensive
options to people and I just think they
overreached with this one I think this
one was too pricey particularly for who
they wanted to go after and there's a
lot of people pointing out in
chat that Vegas has had a Star Trek
Experience for quite some
time and you don't pay nearly as [__]
much granted you don't spend nearly as
much time and it's not nearly as
immersive but just feels like they
[__] themselves over by making it as
expensive as they did no it if they had
sold it like I really think if they had
sold it
corporately which was like Hey Kevin
Smith like you've got 40 employees at
smodco maybe like all all of your
different little businesses like we can
we promise you at the end of these three
days that your people are going to be
functioning as a team way better or hey
Google or hey Amazon or hey Microsoft or
hey any giant Fortune 500 company you
know I did I was telling Mark before the
show I went on a tour of um Summit Ranch
which is what used to be Big Rock Ranch
where they used to make uh clone wars
and it is a very very high-end Corporate
Retreat place where uh Silicon Valley
money spends way more than what I spent
per person to go and do team building at
this beautiful place and um and I feel
like if they had old star Cruiser like
that it would have been booked by Rich
companies for six
years back to back to
back and then you could have dropped the
price because it would have paid for
itself and open it up to you know Silly
folks like us um Chris Green in chat
said JC I love the bar but if your staff
would play the part would be next level
he wants your staff to pretend that
you're all in
space um you know I mean I was I was I
was just telling JC before before the
show it's that the problem is that you
can't casually do Galactic
starkers you know that not every person
in the world is like I want to [__]
cosplay this [__] for real and I'm
willing to spend the money because the
closest thing I can think of is like
medieval times or Renaissance Fair where
like yeah like there's people there in
costume that are believing it and living
it and like I want to come and do the
test strength I'm eat the turkey legs
I'm going to wear my night and armor
[__] I'm going to be a princess whatever
and then there's people in just jeans
and t-shirts who just kind of want to go
and have a day at the fair and I don't
think you could have like a day on the
star Cruiser and not like be part of it
so and so I think there's there's a
certain self- selecting of the audience
which is not quite as big as oh [__] you
know what I want to do I to have turkey
legs and watch jousting and not have to
actually joust and go home at the end
and go
home Ben bamboo in chat says it's
because they built it around the sequels
instead of the original trilogy and the
price point those two factors together
so I I said the same thing I said the
same thing about the sequel Trilogy
before I went and after I went had
nothing to do with it the sequel Trilogy
the only yeah but that's after that's
after you went you saw what a satisfying
experience it was but
selling something particularly something
that's like
$5,000 you know the smarter play I think
would have been who are you going
after my kid who grew up with the
[__] sequel Trilogy or you going
after me with disposable income who
dreams about being a Jedi and going on a
Star cruise I would assume you're going
after me and if you're going after
me chances of getting me are going to be
a lot higher if you're like you're going
to be hanging with l
you're GNA be hanging with Han you're
GNA be hanging with Princess Le all your
favorite childhood friends rather than
like hey man ray is gonna be there I I
mean I don't disagree but even I mean
like again the spoiler is
like that aspect of it is the
last may not even the last Act of the
movie it's like the climax of The Last
Act of the movie like they are only part
of that EXP erience for 3 to 4 hours
total the rest of it is the characters
that Disney made up to help you along
like the archetype characters to help
you along the journey kind of thing um
it was uh it is a shame it was clo it's
closing I I think I mean I
saw like I know people who've gone who
are like whose wives drag them there
because their wife is a a huge Star Wars
fan and this is a computer programmer
guy has lots of money and he was the I'm
wearing a Tommy Bahama shirt and cargo
shorts type of guy and even he came out
of it and he's like I don't really care
about this stuff but it was pretty
awesome um the other thing about the
price is it's not $5,000 per person it's
$55,000 per room so if you put four
people in a room it's like 6,200 bucks
which again is still expensive but like
I went to dis I took Jon to Disneyland
for the first time a couple weeks ago
and we went down and I was like I'm
going to book a hotel I'm going to book
the Grand Floridian I'm going to take
the family out and rooms at the GL Grand
Floridian were $1,500 a night and I was
like we're going to stay at the Motel 6
across the street which was still 200
$50 a night plus $25 a day parking so
I'm at 600 bucks for my family to go to
Disneyland I don't have to buy Jon a
ticket because she's under three but for
me and jenig go for one day to
Disneyland it was
,000 for my family of three to go so if
like you and me and Mark and Ernie
wanted to go to Star Cruiser we
splitting we're we're paying 1,500 bucks
for two nights it's not that much more
expensive than going and spending two
days at Disney
here yeah the other thing is all the
food is included and you know and it's
actually as command Z pointed out in
chat I need $5,000 to pay bills and buy
groceries like that is a lot of [__]
money man and it's a lot of [__]
money and if I'm if I'm spending $5,000
if I'm spending whatever the [__] for 45
hours I love you guys but I want my own
[__]
room it's like and that also seems to be
their miscalculation was that I should
be able to as a person spending $1,500 a
night have my own bed in my own room
with my own door and my own shower and
like the weird forced bunking of like oh
no this is for families nope not this
crowd this C most of this crowd single
without kids and so like what the [__]
are you guys doing like it just seems as
if a great idea was
somewhat continually dinged by a series
of not particularly smart decisions um
some of them being Financial some of
them being designed but it sounds as if
I mean if you if you could swallow all
of that stuff if you can go and
surrender yourself to it like you seem
like a transformed dude like you seem
like a guy who came out of it
remembering how to play and that is 100%
worth that money but it's not worth that
money for everybody and it's it's
[__] Jurassic Park like maybe we can
have a coupon
day like not not for that much money I'm
not gonna go see
dinosaurs um wow man you Brea in rare
air see you you [__] you you saw a
piece of the Star Wars universe that not
a lot of us will ever see do you think
they'll ever make it Canon like throw
away some reference to it like hey man
they had trouble on Star Cruiser so the
cannon that has been written into it
is uh and I guess it's in a comic book
or a novel I think it's in a novel is
that Han and Leia had their honeymoon on
the star
Cruiser and if you go down to the
engineering room I didn't see it but
apparently there's
a corner of the engineering room where
there's HS and like Lo in a heart that
they scratched into the into the wall
which is kind of fun oh that's cute
that's
adorable um but yeah it was it was
awesome also like I'll throw up a couple
pictures because I was nerding out but
like I was at Disney in
full Star Wars cosplay these are my
buddies I went with um which for Disney
nuts like you don't get to uh like this
is me with the Millennium Falcon like
you don't get to this is me uh throwing
it in Disney's face I've got a scum and
villain challenge coin at ogus Cantina
um look at you Disney kids don't get to
like you don't get
to cosplay at the parks like that you
know you don't get to do that anywhere
you know except ability Cantina which
you can wear whatever cosplay you want
want and bring your lightsaber
in Disney
bounding yeah I mean that wasn't
bounding that was just like I'm a Star
Wars guy uh Star Wars bounding
yeah Christopher weeks in chat says
Disney has lost Middle
America I don't know they've lost Middle
America but they certainly priced him
out with the [__] Star Wars
Hotel I mean to be fair they priced them
out with Disneyland my my kid's uh
preschool teacher I was telling her we
were going down to Disneyland and I was
like I can't believe we spent ,000 at
Disney just to go for one day and she
goes I have three kids and there were
times where I priced it out and she flew
her family of five to Orlando and bought
parkhopper tickets for a week in Orlando
and got an Airbnb for less money than it
would have cost to do 3 days at
Disneyland down here because my Airbnb
in Orlando my $250 plus parking Hotel in
Anaheim my Airbnb in Orlando for a
two-bedroom Airbnb was 70 bucks a
night so I got three days in Orlando for
one night in
Anaheim at an Airbnb so it is I mean
like Disney has Disney's so
like you know it's for privilege I mean
it seems the best way to spend time on a
on a ship um and have it be immersive is
to go on the cruise of skew in February
there you go well done my friend
excellent segue kids we're almost I
think we're at 78% sold man Cruz goes in
February Jane Silent Bob's Cruz of
skew join us on the high seas my friends
um we announced our programming schedule
this week so you could see what shows
you're in for um 3,000 of us on a boat
including me and Mark JC you going or no
uh I was not offered to go but I would
have declined anyway because the only
thing on the on Earth that scares me
more than like I mean really the thing I
have nightmares about is Open Water
right like a rogue way I've watched
every Discovery Channel show and like
being on a deck and looking out and
seeing nothing but water like makes me
Shake in my chair in Los Angeles I
actually looked up when we bought our
house I looked up the elevation of our
house to make sure if a giant tsunami
came that we would be above the level
I'm like that crazy about it um and
we're at500 ft so like we're good um
find water like JC kids well then join
us J crues Q go to job cruises q.com
right now sign up for tickets I keep
running into people in the real world
who are like oh I bought tickets to the
cruise I'm gonna see you on the cruise
and stuff it's very nice it sounds J
awesome but me and Mark will be there
for sure it sounds amazing JC likes to
go through cruises in space not on the
yeah that don't actually go anywhere
near them that are actually just a
warehouse in Central Florida
firmly on the
ground uh DK Daniel 01 in chat said
listening to the start of the episode
Kevin thinking that theaters don't care
if you pay for tickets and rating
systems not mattering just baffling this
guy both owns a theater and makes movies
yes so why is that baffling I have
empirical evidence as a theater owner
that like me and Ernie wouldn't give a
[__] less if you came in and skipped
around you paid for one movie and
skipped around all day at that theater
and [__] chances are you can buy
popcorns more [__] [__] and that's
where you make money anyway so I don't
understand why it's baffling that I say
that when I own a theater like that's
why I say it because I know where of I
[__] speak and ratings don't mean a
thing in our theater like I think if a
kid came in and wanted to pay to see
[__] something rated at R I can't
imagine the kids behind the counter
selling tickets are going to be like
you're not old enough especially because
we live in an age of like you we going
tell some kid who can't see an R-rated
movie and then it kid be like all right
I'll go outside and look at PornHub on
my [__] phone like it's ridiculous um
so yeah I brought those things up um
because I own a movie theater and
because I am a filmmaker I don't I don't
see why that's baffling in any
event um okay enough Star Wars um shall
we into the news for heaven's sakes
um we have a we have a modum of new
things to talk about uh got a couple of
rumors which uh have not in any way been
verified by anybody but the internet
seems to be talking about them hey hold
on one sec because I got some people in
chat going like Kev is promoting movie
hopping malicious tactics says I love
this man not at other movie theaters I
can't tell you what to do but you buy
one ticket to a movie at SM castle and
you want to hop around all day you got
my [__] permission now if you get
caught by SM Castle keeper Ernie
O'Donnell you play this portion of the
show for
him that'll get you out of Dutch man
because remember the police station's
like literally one block from the movie
theater so before Ernie calls the cops
on you just be like hey look what your
boy said on the
internets you'll be fine that's how you
get around the [__] SM Castle Cinemas
rules kids stick around here on fat man
beyond we'll tell you all sorts of
inside dope as to how to get over on
Smart
castle and if you want to do it like an
AMC or a Regal or whatever like listen
just go to the bathroom when they're
cleaning out theaters go back into
whatever screen you want to go into sit
in the first two rows nobody buys those
[__] seats especially during the day
nobody's gonna give a [__] and if
somebody does buy that seat move to an
empty seat it's all
good um I can't
Advocate you know people sneaking into
other movie theaters but I can't
Advocate sneaking into mine you pay for
one you pay for one
flick I'm a happy camper buy some
popcorn green Hopper passs yeah you know
what we make money off of not the movies
[__] popcorn soda candy and [__] like
that so if you wanted to come in like we
have five screens if you wanted to come
in you know at first show in the
afternoon and you bought a
ticket you [__] B for $7 you could
see five [__] movies as far as I'm
concerned there I said cut two one year
now SM Castle Cinema is out of
business because he said don't playing
this clip
going Ernie AIS is on the news talking
about
why I'm not a good I'm not a smart
businessman never have been
enthusiastic yeah and if anything I'm
clever but I'm not smart if I was smart
I'd be [__] fabulously wealthy and
I'm a working stiff Mark I mean I'm not
like trying to say I don't make money
granted I get overpaid to do what it is
I do but I I have to hustle it's not
like a lot of people thought like oh he
sold clerks he was set for
life we sold clerks we made clerks for
27 Grand on my credit cards we sold it
for 227
grand um and that money's long [__]
gone money was gone in like
1995 and it's not like oh man but
[__] when they buy your movie you
make money forever no they make money
forever Whoever has it now I think
paramont owns it
now um so yeah I but don't get me wrong
I'm not crying poor and [__] but like I
gotta you know I just had an auction
where I sold a bunch of
artwork uh last week a bodner's auction
house we sat online for like [__] six
hours and I sold 170 lots a bunch of
comic book artwork that I own from comic
books that I absolutely love and comic
books that I absolutely worked on as
well which I also love um but you
know I wouldn't have been doing that if
we hadn't been living through [__]
two strikes and you know lean times and
stuff like that so I'm not uh I I ain't
crying poor like when when I could get
work going I work in a business where
people reward you ridiculously for doing
stupid [__] like Jay says snooch to the
nooch but that being said hi are you
looking for the dogs can you grab me a
Celsius thank you um precommercial for
Celsius right there so so yeah I I'm
this you know again I'm not crying poor
but it's just I I have to work like
there are people I read about all the
time that are like you know my
contemporaries who are [__] sick rich
like if they didn't want to [__]
communicate for a living anymore they
would never have to in this lifetime um
I the reason you still see me all the
time kids is because I'm [__] I'm
broke I gotta
work hustling bman save me go I will I
will say this is that uh you and I have
had many many uh business discussions
and you have successful successfully run
a comic book shop which is like the most
small ball money not me
for Walter Flanigan ran it for years and
now Mike zaps runs it for years if I was
put in charge years
ago fair
enough um yeah just lucky and and
sometimes clever and that's it the older
I get the more I start to realize that
like oh my
God fact that [__] worked out for you is
a minor miracle you should count your
[__] blessings and I've always been
grateful person and [__] probably had
something to do with being raised
religious you know because my mom beat
that into me um not beat it into me
physically but just you know into the
head into the heart and [__] like that
but um yeah no I'm I'm a working stiff
man it's just when I work they overpay
me thank
God that's why you risk it that's why
you're like I'm gonna [__] bet on
myself and make a movie because you
dream of living in a world where like
all the people you grew up watching and
admiring that you could make a liveing
make and
pretend that's my favorite thing I don't
give a [__] how much I make like it you
know I don't have to be the highest paid
guy in the room and believe me I never
am I just love that I get paid to make
pretends I don't care whether it's 10
bucks or 10,000 or well I've never made
10 million but like you know it doesn't
matter if it's two figures three figures
four figures five figures six figures
seven figures like making a dime for
making pretend that's the sweetest money
you could possibly [__] spend as far
as I'm
concern amen amen um okay yes of the
week number
one Taylor Swift is playing dazzler in
Deadpool 3 is that 100% for sure that is
not at all confirmed in any way possible
it's a rumor of the week and why is it a
rumor because she showed up to the chief
Jets football game because she seems to
be dating Travis Kelce tight end for the
the Kansas C Chiefs show up to this I
don't know him as that guy but I know
him as he was a Saturday Live guest host
last year he was very funny he was
indeed he's a pitch man for lots of
things because he's a Charming Man um
but you showed up to this game with Ryan
Reynolds Hugh Jackman and Deadpool 3
director sha Ley in
toe that is the source of the
rumor could be look if if that wasn't
the case and I'm Shan Levy and I just
read that online my next phone call is
to be like hey do you want to come play
dazzler like what a great idea that is
that is a phenomenal [__]
idea sh you're talking about one of the
biggest [__] you know music act on
the
planet playing a Marvel character known
for wait for it
singing like it's a no [__] brainer
yes so there is no nothing resembling
confirmation about this it is pure
speculation but hey if it's true cool if
it isn't okay just as good rumor of the
week number
two Christopher Nolan is in negotiation
to direct the next two James Bond movies
why is this a rumor that's a rumor that
is a rumor I you know
honestly he's uh you know clearly one of
the best filmmakers alive
um this is a dude who is just coming off
of the threeh hour R-rated Oppenheimer
movie which is close to a billion
dollars
yes I don't know what you follow that
with
but doing a James Bond movie when you
were the guy who redefined Batman as an
action
franchise really tracks for me like you
know [__] Batman has way more action
than your average James Bond movie I
feel like
so it seems like he'd be very
comfortable in that director chair for
that particular
franchise I mean like could he do it
100% like
everybody of a certain age grew up I
mean hell everybody of a lot of Ages
grew up with James Bond in their lives
as a Brit James Bond is a bit of a sort
of National Treasure that Brits get to
handle every now and again um the and
the only reason why it's a thing that
could happen potentially is if he just
likes it and has a soft spot for Bond um
but it's not as if it's a job he needs
to take um and there is no substance to
this rumor other than some dude on the
internet was like I'm going to make up a
rumor apparently um but like and I don't
know it I don't know what's in it for
him Beyond
Nostalgia because I mean you don't get
that much free reaying with Bond um he
can do whatever he wants to do and it's
Bond the thing he wants to do I don't
know [__] it maybe um it seems a little
a little weird to me but then again
again I don't know what's in that dude's
head maybe like Spielberg always wanted
to make a James Bond movie and then they
didn't let him so he made Indiana
Jones
um hey maybe no one's got a Bond movie
in him and they're looking and they'll
pay him whatever he wants to be the guy
who relaunches the next James Bond in
the post Daniel Craig Universe like all
right
sure maybe or maybe not it's just the
room of the week don't put it on put it
on my neck I could uh I could see it you
know and sometimes a dude just wants to
Throttle Down you know like he pulled
off a miracle with that Oppenheimer
picture dude's like let me take it easy
and make a Bond
movie God bless God bless uh now for
some real news um James gun has revealed
the actors um from previous iterations
of the DCU that will survive into the
new iteration the DCU um according to Mr
gun nothing is Cannon until Creature
Commandos next year a sort of aatif to
the DCU and then a deeper dive into the
universe with Superman Legacy after that
um it's a very human drive to want
understand everything all the time but I
think it's okay to be confused on what's
happening in the DCU since no one has
seen anything from the DCU yet and yet
he continues some actors will be playing
characters they've played in other
stories and some plot points might be
consistent with plot points from the
dozens of films shows and animated
projects that had come from DC in the
past nothing is Canon until Creature
Commandos in
Legacy but he did say that via Davis is
set to reprise her role as Amanda
Waller um for Creature
Commandos um he said that uh and I'm
going to mispronounce his name I'm sure
Zolo
mariduena uh will factor into the new
plans and will continue playing Blue
Beetle in the
DCU and John Cena will persist as
Peacemaker um he did not say anybody
else that we've seen before is part of
the cannon we'll be going forward but I
suppose technically he didn't say that
anybody wouldn't
be take that as you will fans reading
tea
leaves did
uh how do I say this
I you know I I'm there have been so
many maybe it's because I clicked on one
or two over the you know the beginning
of the life of this story but like in my
Google the algorithm of my Google news
page feeds me so many James gun
stories um and I know it's not James
gun's fault I know people are just you
know
[__] excited about where the DC
Universe could be going or curious about
where the DC Universe is going or they
understand that there's a whole audience
on the internet curious about it so they
put up their hot takes likes and
dislikes and [__] like that
but I you know I'm I'm ready to stop
talking about all of it until we start
seeing a movie like still seems we're
like a year off from seeing a [__]
motion picture right I mean at least you
know Superman Legacy is that like
2025 um I mean there just now I mean he
posted some pictures of them putting up
Superman pictures Superman artwork in
the production offices for Superman
Legacy which is like yeah you know the
we haven't touched the script in three
and a half four months because we
haven't been able to um storyboarding
has continued and some design work has
continued but you know and casting
clearly is happen but I have no idea how
far they are from even production um to
the point where now we're in October of
23 having a giant [__] Superman movie
ready for
24 possible um maybe by next Christmas
if we wanted it if he wanted it um but
also just as likely you know summer
25 so I guess we can keep talking what
it crazy that like what what month are
we in we're in OCT October
so it's only three months ago that flash
happened yeah and like two months ago
the Blue Beetle
happened one month ago the Blue Beetle
happened although there was
August I I mean you could be right
because it's now on [__] iTunes maybe
it's on Mac it's on [__] Max already
but remember is it really no I think it
is um but remember going into this
summer like how [__] excited we all
were for the
flash
well not sure we all I still no regrets
man like when it comes to Michael Keaton
Batman stuff that's
still was such a fun highlight of my
summer 2023 was like getting to take a
trip back in time a little bit to
1989 got your ke back I did man I did
get my ke back for a red hot minute and
[__]
um all right what else we got um
speaking of DC businesses um walrus
onion in chat said you were excited Kev
was fair enough fair enough maybe it
maybe it wasn't all of us but it did
seem like it was not just me yes um Fear
The Walking Deads Coleman Domingo is
tackling the role of bat man for a new
DC Spotify podcast oh right on called
The Riddler secrets in the dark um
comedian Hassen Minaj um stars as the
Riddler and secrets in the dark um after
having voiced him in spotify's Batman
unburied um the new series which uh
which premieres apparently in five days
October 10th forces Batman to team with
Edward digma to stop a mysterious
vigilante who's killing Gotham's
villains including the Riddler Winston
Duke was the previous actor who who
voiced Batman and Batman unburied um the
cast of secrets in the dark includes
Gina Rodriguez as Barbara Gordon Kellum
wy's the messenger Hannah Simone as
Nadira um Jason Isaac as Alfred Ashley
bur as Vicky Veil
um yeah like there's a bunch of [__]
King Tut is in this [__] which is kind
of dope oh is that right yeah uh let's
see King Tut B calender man is in it
Arnold flas is in it Killer Croc is in
it King created for
television based on what Batman
villain oh I don't know that Maxi Zeus
ah I think if I remember correctly I
think I think Maxi Zeus came first or
I'm wrong and Maxi Zeus came after and
it's based on King to somebody will tell
me in chat I'm sure sure [__] you
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about um and finally uh word on the
street is that Marvel is beginning to
take meetings with writers about the
X-Men that uh the big last giant thing
get on it man before kid before people
lose their appreciation for this [__]
like superhero fatigue seems to be a
very real thing
and get to it man you know I used to
think they had all the time in the world
because that Marvel Brand would go on
forever but
you better get them mutants on stage
quick yeah yeah there needs to be some
focus at work and I'm not entirely sure
that we are we're we're we're in the
presence of focus in the MCU at this
point and so I mean you know the word
was like that was their big priority in
the heels of the writer strike coming to
an end was we got to start Fielding
pitches and taking meetings with with
various writers around town to do the
X-Men and you
know Sally fourth
men women and everybody in between um
Good Luck to those entering the Hunger
Games Vex in chat has this suggestion I
would have an easier time with these
audio dramas if they published exclusive
Comics to go with them hard not having
visuals with Batman for me it's an
excellent
idea that's they're leaving money on the
table why wouldn't you do a [__]
comic to go along with your audio drum
you know so you can follow along like
and turn the page and [__] remember when
they they'd give you the plastic records
in the comics that you have to put
Pennies on the actual like put a coin
here to weigh the record
down
otherwise oh that's technology that
should come back what else we got um
that my friend is about it it covers all
new huh we remain in in the in the sort
of the dir of news given that it's start
to have news when actors aren't on stage
to shoot the the [__] we're looking for
when scripts for the new stuff is only
just being written so there's not a ton
of development business at
work it's uh it's hard to say and we
still don't want to be shills for stuff
so I don't want to talk too much about
trailers chicken monkey 33 in chat said
y all listen to the Squirrel Girl
podcast it was cute as hell not see I
didn't even know there was one of
those
um Travis Huffman says no politics in my
nerd news please did we talk about
politics I don't believe we did at all
yeah I don't think we did when
Iota um all right well I guess that's we
could if you want yeah crazy [__] happen
I've got
thoughts um let's uh let's uh agree that
the news portion of our show is over
indeed indeed and let's uh bring B man
back to the platform B man B there he is
[__] fresh from his Star cruise look
at him all refreshed and Youthful and
[__] I know man like [__] there is
hope and magic in the world still got a
new lease online you know what I you
know what I came away with as I was
walking out I was talking to my friends
and I was like why don't I dress like
this every day like yes you got you
could get away with that in your bar and
they were like why don't you and I was
like you know what I [__] could I'm
like one of the guys who actually could
dress like this every day you're the one
yeah you could literally dress like grad
Adil th thwn every [__] day at your
job if you wanted
to um do you see my challenge coin JC
look how huge it is yeah that's pretty
that's a challenge Fu my friend is that
a is that like goodie bag you get when
you subscribe at a certain level or is
that a yes when you join that Kevin
Smith Club I think this is like the
basic level is the challenge
coins then the next level up is this
bound scripts do you get to choose which
coin you get or is it random no there's
uh there will be four of them throughout
this year so they four different eras of
my four different looks
so the last coin is me and jackets the
next after these two of course there's
me and a hockey jersey then there's me
and jackets but uh Luke and Chelsea and
Jordan they're responsible for bringing
these to life man they're pretty dope
that Kevin Smith
club.com kids if you're into that sort
of nonsense and [__] I gotta reach out
to Luke I have uh Taylor is watching
Joselyn now is that right Taylor is in
luk Taylor Taylor tayor yeah yeah so
keeping it in the SM family literally
it I need to reach out I want to do new
challenge coins for scum and villain so
I I that's where I got the idea from I
mean you for you everywhere in the world
people always hand me challenge coins
but when you did them I was like oh [__]
we should be doing them yours are way
fancier than ours are but yeah they kind
of went crazy not crazy but they're
they're pretty big ass [__] coin you
drop one of these from a building kill
human being please don't W walrus onion
says Two Face coins [__] you could do
your face and then your face scratched
out should do scratched out [__] Coin
that's true um all right uh q& a I
imagine you got some q's and I imagine
we some A's um I like uh I liked this
one this is Lucas McGregor uh I was
raised Catholic you were raised Catholic
Mark were you raised religious at
all no I was I was a funeral wedding the
only times I set foot in the church
lucky uh yeah this is uh Lucas McGregor
um on the day that you pass away and
float up to the Pearly Gates you're not
greeted by St Peter or Jesus or any of
that BS but by an IP character who is it
and how would they judge
you so I guess who who do you want to
greet you at the game to heaven and uh
what would they say to
you Batman Kevin Conroy
Batman and uh he would say to me
um I'm proud of
you you led a a
Batman a Batman adjacent life you don't
want a Batman life because then your
parents have to be killed in an alley
and you're always [__] emo and [__]
but a Batman adjacent life Batman
approved that that would be enough for
me if he was I got there and Batman was
like surprised and I'm like they gave me
a big hug and [__] Cape around me and
whatnot not in a creepy way not in a
romantic way in a [__] like you know
my God my hero is holding me kind of way
because he's bigger right like he ain't
like man siiz he's like he's like a
three up right because he's God so when
he holds you you feel Batman standing on
top of each other's shoulders like
basically like Ultron essentially every
Batman you've ever loved comes together
in one giant Batman that can cradle you
in his arms and tell you what a good job
you did in life um yeah I I'll take
Batman I know there's a bunch of
mystical figures I could be going for
and [__]
but [__] you know Batman Batman is
uh you know he walks the line between
man and God you
know
I
think I well because he's a man but he's
like this is a guy who could fight
[__] Superman hold his own toe-to-toe
with [__] Superman or Wonder
Woman This is a man who plays at being
God or or walks with
Gods
um so I you know yeah Batman more so
than Superman you'd imagine I'd be like
oh I meet
Superman but
Superman's approval wouldn't mean as
much to me as Batman's
approval I mean I maybe that's wrong to
say let me
think n Superman's pretty cool like I
guess Superman's approval would mean as
much as Batman's approval I'm just a
bigger Batman fan I mean that's all fair
it's like somebody asked me the other
day like some Jersey quiz they were like
Bruce Springstein or Bon joy and I was
like well that's [__] not fair
like well Frank ra well that that would
have been easy but like [__] bruer
Bon JY that's can't be an or Bruce and
Bon Joby yes what I
say
um what about you who's who's waiting in
heaven for you um I think that for me
you know the the pearly gates open up
and this man comes walking over in like
a purple coat with a cane you know and
just very slowly comes up and then the
cane sticks in the clouds and then he
does a tumble and a flip and then he
stands up and then he says you
get nothing for you and then I get a
little weepy and whatever and then I
give him the [__] Everlasting Gob
stoer he says Ah so shines a good deed
in a weary world and then he's like come
on in it's amazing in we got glass
elevators we got chocolate fountains we
got fat kids who float the sea feelings
we got trains that go nowhere but make
you kind of puke we got it all it's the
best version of Heaven um that for me is
what I want it's not that then [__] it
you've literally just
changed you've turned it you've turned a
a song into a church Himel if you want
to view
Paradise simply look around and view
what is more Paradise than uh you know
the notion of heaven and [__] I like it
I like Willie woner run in heaven
absolutely and then it's like then it's
like Sister Act is the Himel when
they're like if
you a whole [__] like Kirk Franklin
choirs going to work and it's a Baptist
Church really I like it are you ready
for a miracle
ready I like it very much yes James
Brown comes out like in The Blues
Brothers and the [__] are just
flipping on
[__] I like your version of Heaven
better than mine mine's a batcave where
a lone [__] man in a in a giant
Halloween costume waits to give you a
hug yours sounds more fun than mine good
time Heaven uh what about you B man who
do you want to see on the other side if
I am if I am approaching Heaven I think
I want lonus from the
peanuts a that's just he just seems like
he's not real judgy he kind of has a
grasp on what life is is all about he
gives a good speech when it comes time
to be you know religious uh in Charlie
Brown Christmas if you're sad he's got a
blanket for
you you know he's a good best
friend be and he's always he'll sit
there and he'll do the monologue from
the
Bible God bless us
everyone I'll tell you what life was
about JC renberg that's right hit by a
spotlight and narrate your life back to
and the greatest moment of your life was
when you went on the Star cruise
that's uh speaking of which question
number two from Nightshade
Holloway uh if you could have an
immersive experience that works
perfectly and does not glitch out like
Westworld what movie would you want to
live in for a
weekend
all right do one more
time uh if you could have an immersive
experience that works perfectly and does
not glitch out like Westworld what movie
would you want to live in for a
weekend
H the Bad News
Bears
the answer that was so much gravity like
the bad news bear Bad News
Bears
um yeah but that's that's only that that
would just be because then I'd be young
in the 70s I don't know if that would I
could go into any movie I don't know
that that's the one I go into or you're
Walter
MAA true yeah true in my head I'm still
part of the team but when I get there
you're an old man are you the coach I'm
like me what no no I'm [__] like
engleberg they're like no you're a grown
ass
man you just paid money to come here
this isn't like magic you could have
gone into any movie and you came to this
one it's just baseball man yeah and you
don't even like
baseball don't didn't you wasn't your
idea of Heaven having a Batman there why
did you choose this
picture I don't know man The Valley in
the 70s just really captures my
imagination now I live in the
valley and it ain't the 70s but but when
I drive around here I think the one of
the reasons I'm here is because I've
watched the valley and movies my whole
life growing up starting with the Bad
News Bears um but let's see where would
I like to go totally immersive it
wouldn't Westworld
out
um oh
I would go to the Vic
Universe a yeah oh my God I'd be hiled
like a god I would be God
there I'd be meeting all my creations
and [__] like that they'd [__] be be
they they have to treat me well
right yeah like there's no to killing me
like kill him he's here now we'll we'll
be free it's nothing like that it'll
just be like the Bob is here the Bob is
here the Bob is here would should be
very confusing because there is a bob in
that Universe already it's like bro I'm
just
working he whose view is a
skew um yeah man I'd go to my [__]
world and [__] I'd be eating out like
crazy on [__] you know you know I
created all this right they're like well
this way sir please have a seat I'd be
like
[__] Henry Hill and [__] good
Fellas man they take me through the
[__] downstairs up through the
restaurant walking out I'm right at the
edge of the stage
[Laughter]
Frank um yeah that's how limited my
imagination is I would go into my own
[__] movie something I could do
without this magical ability I could
literally just do it myself by writing a
thing but I think I would like to
physically go visit my
characters it's
cool how about you where you going
um I uh part of me is like
Blade Runner what that world doesn't
seem like too much fun but like it's a
big [__] it's a big build right like
it's like you're in another place in
another time and that seems like it
could be cool um that I was also similar
like the Matrix but like that's also
like if you're just a [__] NPC in The
Matrix I don't know how much fun you're
having but then I was like you know
where I want to [__] go I want to go
to shaft world I want to be [__]
shaft and I just I just want to be the
the black private dick that's a sex
machine with all the chicks I just want
to pimp slap a bunch of [__] shoty
white businessmen I want to wear cool
pants I want to have all kinds of sex
with crazy [__] freaky people you're
a complicated man but no one understands
you like your woman not at all that's
what I want Beverly Hills Cop featuring
Jay I like that yeah I mean [__] Star
Trek is also pretty cool like if you're
if you're just like an NPC on the
Enterprise like Josh H mentioned the
Enterprise Next Generation era I'm like
well yeah maybe but also like any
[__] Star Trek as long as you don't
have a red shirt and you're not like a
yman Johnson who's preceding Kirk on an
away Mission like that's a pretty decent
Lighty Evan Fowler in chat says I want
to go into the last star fighter I want
to take down the Rodan Armada while a
faceless clone bangs my wife that's
hysterical that's the C cold retelling
of [__] last star
fighter whole
time Alex Rogan is [__] taking down
the the kodan Armada or whatever the
[__] in the back of his mind he's like
what's hot about this is my wife is
banging a faceless clone back on Earth
yeah the music man is railing my
wife they weren't even married they were
just like boyfriend girlfriend but I
guess this guy in his version in his in
his life like my wife is banging a weird
ass [__] faceless guy does she care
question you should ask her if she
cares um like did what's her name care
in the movie did she ever find out that
it was [__] she does because like
[__] it starts to like twig out or
whatever right it's not it's not Robert
pressing it's Robert
no no no Robert Preston takes him yeah
but it's the Clone he leaves behind
right do the whole thing come cannot
compute come yeah like is a space falls
off right isn't that doesn't that happen
and then he's eating her out and his
face falls off if I remember
correctly gg kid she's
like 1985 was a hell of a year yeah that
was how I learned what Kingus was
because of and then she runs outside
like where are
you B man you got a movie you want to be
trapped in or TV show well you were
trapped in it already as lame as it is
I'd like probably go back to Star
Cruiser again but if I if there was
anything else the other childhood thing
I want to be a [__] Ghostbuster I
want to live in 1984 New York City with
a proton pack and fight the ghosts of
dead cab drivers and stuff I think that
would be
awesome Jose monster his answer in chat
Takes the Cake he says I want to go to
the Eyes Wide Shut
[Laughter]
Universe watch Nicole Kidman pee a
universe of one
movie but everywhere but Jose's got a
point like that'd be [__] up man like
that's an orgy Planet essentially
all day every day yeah that's right
you're always walking into a room
there's dudes and robes and canes and
people listlessly [__] on a couch in
front of
you listlessly [__]
world what's happening here just
nobody's on a good time they've had so
much sex they don't care about it
anymore look how listless that sex
is what are you doing I'm [__] this
person yeah I guess I guess I'm kind of
[__] boring
somehow heartbreak feels good in a place
like
this yo I found that movie theater the
the the one that Nicole Kidman shot that
ad the AMC ad somebody found it yeah
somebody found and I went there it's in
Porter Ranch yeah they had opened an AMC
there they built an AMC That was
supposed to open and then the pandemic
happened and so they never [__]
opened it but that's where they shot
that Adge if you walk down that hallway
it's the same [__] hallway if you go
in that theater the same [__]
theater just saying guys I found the
treasure map to the worst commercial
ever
made
um B Ranch California I think Patty
lapel the pin makers made a pin of that
like [__] Nicole Kidman that's
amazing AMC thing I mean that's got to
be a photo op how many people are just
going there Monday morning for a MAA to
get the Instagram I know to get the
hallway with the numbers on each side I
did it they should have a cardboard cut
out of Nicole kimman
there see they're not thinking they're
not thinking like businessmen SL
women um all right third question of the
evening all right last one is from uh
Beyond
retaliation uh they say rumors that
Clayface will be the villain in Batman 2
who would you two cast for the role of
Clayface in the uh R patch Batman
Universe I want to play clay
phase which clay phase is he is he the
actor Clayface or is he matad Haagen
Clayface uh was not specified I think
Clayface Batman animated
series
just a big moving massive goo how are
they gonna pull that character off and
[__] this very realistic world like
that's the whole catch of the the pitch
of that Batman is like this is Batman if
it was real man like Clayface is one of
the least realistic Batman villains on
the
planet um I mean maybe they go like
serious body horror with it maybe it's
not like giant mound of brown goo and
maybe it's more like the dude from
RoboCop whose face starts to melt oh my
God the shirt off man yeah yeah I've
always felt like people were like what
do you look like you know I was like in
movies you kind of look for your body
type somebody's like what do you look
like I look like that dude in Robocop
when he gets the nuclear [__] dropped
on just a melting human being and
[__] uh
um all right so who would I cast as as
said person yeah John
Ham oh
wow excellent is the actor so you go the
prettiest man in the world you go but
who also got some age on him he's not
like a young dude he's been an actor
he's been trying to work for a while and
it's not working
out um is uh
Peter OU still alive he is not damn
it he'd have been a great [__]
Clayface um God you know who an amazing
Clayface Allen
Rickman again Allen wouldn't have been
would have been an amazing
anything anything that dude could have
played the [__] out of any
part
you know sooner or later he would have
been
Alfred oh
100%
100% still
waying oh could you imagine him like he
would be the kind of Alfred that is you
know like [__]
Stern very British and [__] but like
when he you know like can you imagine
him giving the whole like why do we fall
down
great
um I like your John
Ham Hank Hank Hills in chat says
Nicholas Cage which would also be pretty
[__]
great Nicholas Cage bro that's a [__]
answer right there I'm still response
Nick Cage as [__]
Clayface oh that's
fantastic
B got B I'm going to do Dave filon Ron
Pearlman just bring him
over he he voiced an animated series
didn't he according to my quick Google
why is that a uh what did you refer to
that a Dave filon where you take you
take the animated character and you
bring him into the live action copy um
okay and who are you doing this with Ron
Pearlman who voiced Clayface in Batman
the Animated Series right did he
really that's uh according to Batman
Wikipedia
yeah although wouldn't Dave F wouldn't
doing a Dave filon then just recast it
because he did not bring Ashley Xin well
he he brought Michelson and and Katie
sack
off over okay fair
David haror for
[Music]
clay somebody said Jim Carrey cross
Crossman Jeff said Jim
Carrey seen him do a villain
though Clancy Brown is Clay fix oh yeah
boat said stepen colar is the clock King
yeah Clancy Brown is Clayface sounds
more
familiar as the clock King is something
I never imagined but oh my God that's
so I mean coar is as the Riddler is also
pretty great
yeah
um now we're just jerking off saying
names
is that you do when your jerk off you
just say names you're like Clancy
Brown Michael
Sarah did you guys see did you guys see
that news story that on the DVD or the
Blu-ray for super bad that they actually
had Michael Sarah do that dance for one
hour on a green screen so that the menu
would
like
uh they thought Rogan and and Evan
thought it would be funny if people sat
there waiting for the menu to Loop and
it never looped so there was behind the
scenes footage of Michael Sarah doing
that dance for an hour nonstop for super
bad that seems just wrong no wonder no
wonder he's so thin wild Samurai in chat
said Jack black as Clayface as did Corey
Taylor that's a great suggestion right
there that's a great
idea like black can do no wrong yeah
truly uh look at that folks just like
that it's all
over how many hours we've been doing
this [__] uh two hours and5 minutes
almost three good Lord time to give the
people their lives back kids you have a
good time I know I did about this [__]
uh a lot of people in chat were like do
this every week number one don't tell us
what to do number two we're trying um
now the movie's out of the way and stuff
we could get back to more regular
schedule some live in person I know at
the scum and villain Cantina did we hook
up a date or not yet not not yet we're
we're waiting on your ridiculous crazy
travel schedule I'm back uh
uh say October 20th and then I'm back
for a long time okay what are my next
things I got October 12th to the 15th
smodcastle Film Festival tickets on sale
right now go to smodcastle cinemas.com
uh in November I think I want to say
it's November 11th we've got uh Zach and
Mary Make a Porno 15th anniversary at SM
Castle Cinemas and then on December 2nd
we're doing
Smokin you know we do auctions before
like most the screenings we do we're
doing a whole show that's nothing but
auction just never ending
auction so if you're like oh what do I
get some the person that likes these
stupid ass Kevin Smith movies for
Christmas come to smoking because we're
gonna do it online as
well so I'm I'm around for uh you know
for most of the end of the year out here
in Los Angeles cool cool it's a lot to
hook it up we'll have to hook it up
indeed um give it up for uh bman right
there man without whom we you don't see
us me and Mark just be talking to each
other and [__] I know he took the bullet
and went to Galactic star Cruiser for us
take a bullet [__] made his life
sounded
like he's gonna start dressing up at his
bar now he's
[__] and he now want I go in there if
I was b b jimp up here B if I'm you I
keep my costume at the bar and like Mr
Rogers I go to work every day and I
[__] put it on yeah
[__] you get to wear capes at your
job if you want to it'd be amazing I
know I don't know why I it took that I
gotta be honest with you I the yesterday
I took this is a selfie stick and I took
it with me um to Rion and recorded a a
meditations a show that I do for that
Kevin Smith Club
um but it hooks like this and I put it
on my I had a like a hoodie tied around
my waist and it looked like a [__]
lightsaber hanging there and I felt so
badass but I was getting looked at by
everybody like going like did he wear a
lightsaber to [__] you know and some
of those people recognize recognize me
so it's not just like did that Rando
it's like did that you know lifelong
Star Wars fan clearly wear a lightsaber
on his way to runan Canyon and what good
does he think that's going to do does he
think he's going to use that [__]
lightsaber to fight fat what is that all
about home defense I felt cool though
having it hooked on me man felt like I
mean I still regret not going to [__]
Galaxy's Edge and buying myself a
lightsaber like getting the custommade
jam one of these days I'll have to fix
it he see I say you do cosplay at the F
work I think I'm just going to start
doing I I mean you know like at smart
Castle I got like [__] 20 different
jackets right like [__] I go to the
cheap suit stores like suit fashion and
[__] buy like a [__] $100 jacket
without the pants I leave the pants
behind and [__] um you could have like
five different [__] bombass outfits
from all across the Star Wars universe
and [__] I feel like also how awesome
would that be is
like your fat man beyond fan from like
Minnesota and you stop and this happens
a lot this happens like there's usually
like a mom or a dad who will come in and
be like we're taking the kids to Disney
but I insisted we flew into LAX so we
could come by here before I have to sit
in Disney for the LA next four days but
how awesome would it be and I'm always
like hey that's awesome thank you so
much and uh and hang out with them but
how much cooler would it be if I was
wearing like you know if I was dressed
like
this yeah you
know like wouldn't you rather hang out
with that guy than this
guy I would love to like ask for the
manager and the manager shows up wearing
a
cape or like we somebody won't leave and
the police show up and I who who's
running this joint I'm like well I am I
am I the chief administrator I'm the
chief administrator of this yes well
well what have we
here um it would encourage others to
cosplay there I bet like if the [__]
owners in costume other people would
feel free to show up in costume how
what's the average uh percentage of
cplay again uh more than any other bar
probably in the country but way less
than people would like um all my
bartenders cosplay though one of them um
does like a really awesome
like uh X-Men the Animated Series Rogue
and she lives just a few blocks away
from the bar so she would wear it down
Hollywood Boulevard to work like the
first two or three times she did it and
she's like I'm just going to leave this
at work from now on I'm not comfortable
walking down Hollywood Boulevard in a
spandex bodysuit like Rogue what's y'all
dream uh kids if you had a good time
tonight it's probably because of bamp
man there or the other dude without whom
there is no [__] show the smart one
if you will although tonight in [__]
chat you were called [__] grouchy old
man for not liking
Ahsoka I mean I'll take it everyone's
like he sounds like a grumpy old man
shaking his fist in a clout give it up I
like anything the old things resident
[__] grumpy old man shaking his fist
out a cloud Mark Bernard ladies and
gentlemen my pleasure boys and
girls um and there it is
kids there's your fat man beyond for
this week man next week we'll come back
we'll chat some
more [__] geeky [__] because
something's gonna happen between now and
then and we're gonna talk about it right
here it don't matter until we talk
about more
Loki uh there it is kids there's your
fat man be on for this week fat man
beond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark bernardy
tune in next time same fat Time same fat
Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevinsmith Jeff's kiss
[__] this is the cat greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA ask
keev anything every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and S Bob
get old up Kevin Smith J